you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country folks
entertainment whole bunch of other stuff
about having a healthy body image you've
a very unhealthy body you should have a
horrible body it's not a big coming
through the market maturity we are
definitely going to get letters you're
listening to talk radio strangest animal
you're getting louder with Crowder
[Music]
glad to be with you that is the sound of
the weekend I am your host you can find
all the references it louder with
Crowder com producing with me in video
studio as always is not GERD who is not
gay follow him on Twitter at not gay
Jared I fulfilled my legal obligations
draw your own conclusions you good we're
good we are good and are comers out
there 15.com big supporters we love them
and I have some new commercials coming
your way this week big guests really big
show we have a full lineup Curt
Schilling Curt Schilling Curt Schilling
up first then we have Sam Kendricks the
viral sensation pole-vaulter bronze
medalist for the United States who well
you know what can we can we run it do we
have that clip but quick like 10 second
we dont't look we don't have a clip
viral sensation who dropped his pole in
the middle of his practice run because a
national anthem was playing and he sat
there and and put his hand over his
heart and honored it and by the way an
Army reservists so great guest then who
and McIlhenny had mcclenney and
McIlhenny to talk about hillary she had
a play regarding hillary clinton with
actual transcripts i think from from the
FBI investigation will ask her and John
Nolte formerly a Breitbart right now
he's kind of a freelancer and big Trump
supporter so big Trump people actually
Curt Schilling and John Nolte yep and
will let them kind of lay out the case
for the Saddam it could be known make it
be known
speaking of which we don't wanna get
into it too much but obviously the big
news story this week is Donald Trump
people are a little upset with what they
perceive as a flip-flop on immigration
because he said no amnesty none ever
announced now I understand where he's
coming from with this so you guys can
now we'll talk with with with Kurt about
it we'll talk with John Nolte about it
probably more so Kurt is going to be
running against Elizabeth Warren I want
to get the skinny on that that should be
hot and excited I want to get the Native
Americans skin I just hope if he does I
shall be it just destroys the narrator
you know Donald Trump is now saying well
maybe they can give them we can work
with them if they pay back taxes he said
he's going to do very similar to what
Obama and George Bush have done which is
a bit of an NZ popular
yes which is further to the left than
what Marco Rubio has done and certainly
than what Ted Cruz has done where they
were a little harsh here's the thing
I hope this is a misspeak I hope it's
not a pivot because I've always said
this about the one thing I liked about
Donald Trump I don't think he's going to
get Mexico to pay for the wall
logistically but I like that he's been
bold enough to talk about illegal
immigration and say no more I've done
that in this show for a long time
because my mom's is a legal immigrant
she was on this show and we borderline
had to pull her back because she gets
pretty harsh on the subject of the
illegal immigration ouncer illegal
illegal the a legal immigrant not
illegal that's right you met my mom for
the first time the first time did it uh
did I had I accurately portrayed her I
think so but the mom jokes are just dead
to me now so I can't it's true there you
have it you have to create fictional
fictional mrs. Stephens mom to say all
the horrendous things we can't do that
tweet me that's creditor to you when you
do the mom joked with your friends do
you sort of compartmentalize that's
that's a hypothetical mother this is the
real mother so you're like not would
never do that to this no that's that one
not that one not the one who doesn't
really exist maybe who looks like I'll
McPherson certain on the edge
good-looking broad good-looking brought
it oh my oh hey also speaking of which
transgenderism has no basis in science
so that's it's not a real thing we wrote
about a lot of interesting things in
that study actually talked about a kind
of an array of sexually the idea that
it's fixed when you're born into the
wrong gender into a wrong body that they
basically said no no that's not that's
not that the gay gene I got talked about
a little bit in a study yep by the way
it doesn't necessarily look with always
said science isn't go is not determined
by consensus but this is yet more proof
that the science isn't in and people
have different opinions and there's some
really negative ramifications to just
pump in someone's balls full of estrogen
believe it or not who knew some could
say problematic so okay speaking of
problematic you know there's there's so
much to get into this week we this was
the one thing that blew up we got it a
little earlier than other people because
my brother went to UT so I actually
subscribed to a lot of the local Austin
news feeds you know in Texas now you're
allowed to carry out why are you
smirking little impress just what do you
know where sorry's going you just
everything's a pun everything is just
fabulous
so please do
we have the video pay no mind and you're
allowed to conceal carry on campus now
in Texas right that's the state law some
social justice leftists were upset there
for dildos let's roll the first clip a
[ __ ] person I'm gonna go with that
one to a very unintelligent person okay
let me set it up for you they were
saying because it's illegal to display
sex toys but not a gun in Texas no there
are plenty of sex shops in Texas you're
just not allowed to have a bunch of
adult paraphernalia out in public in
front of children obviously they don't
really care because this occurred so
they're thinking more uncomfortable with
guns therefore we're going to pass out
these dildos it gets worse and then
we'll get into the meat roll the next
clip next clip there's no way to tiptoe
around this not dangerous if it no you
literally need to go back to remedial
English because the guns are not even
figuratively boning your education what
is this these are these are the kids of
higher guns are literally boning our
education what what is that what does it
even I don't know what that means
yeah but I know that it's incorrect so
this is what's happening with with the
left we have how many more Clips do we
have with this I think it tomorrow okay
we have two more you know what let's
let's let's roll a couple more because
there is something important to macro
here a through-line
if you will to get to let's roll the
next clip
[Applause]
[Music]
and we need you to continue to make
noise do is make noise make noise and
they photograph it to make a look at
there's an actual crowd there here's
what's important for people to know we
write a lot about social justice words
and leftist and the beauty is here to
pendulum is swinging these people are
losing there is a silver lining
politically it looks grim for the United
States right now but people see these
videos they see these stories they get
no interactions nobody likes them there
there's a maybe about a dozen people
there maybe two dozen people call it
three dozen who are running around
shaking dildos to protest guns because
they think that's effective and they're
screaming and they get the headlines but
guess what all the other fifty something
thousand students at UT are just walking
around them if we're a couple hundred
there it would still be a fraction of a
fraction of a minority of people exactly
it is an incredibly small minority and
by the way many of those other people at
UT on campus might vote Hillary they
might vote Bernie but they also know
that this is patently absurd they also
know that these are very unintelligent
people they also know that these are
professional protesters it's like when
you go back to the 60s and people think
it was flower power the hippie era
nobody liked them the top albums were
show tunes
it wasn't the Mamas and the Papas it
wasn't everybody everybody wasn't
smoking grass in Woodstock people didn't
like them people wanted to go to class
it's the same thing here it's why
Chicago was at University of Chicago
I believe so here we go I have it yeah
University of Chicago said hey no
trigger warnings no safe spaces here
they are trying to socially engineer
kids right now and in college the elite
the the selected elite are trying to
decide what's good for the collective
and individuals are rejecting it and
there are more individuals rejecting it
than they then the group they thought
was the collective so it's important to
see this and not get lost in the shuffle
and think oh my gosh this is what's
happening these are all students most of
them aren't it's a very small group of
people we have to address it because it
gets all of the headlines because of the
complicit media who wants you to say
they want you to become complacent to
think the country is
is gone that this is how far we are and
there's no way we can there's no way we
can write this ship let me give you an
example I was over there when we were up
north that breakfast spot you know I'm
like yeah delicious yeah matter of fact
uh good ol days Brian listens to the
podcast thank you you down there at the
Roadhouse so a girl was was serving us I
love her name is Kelly she's wonderful
fantastic server and she was wearing a
sweater and I said hey I said I love the
Bill Cosby sweater was kind of really
hyper ly designed and she said yeah she
said you know it's actually it's like
it's Navajo I got it a thrift verse
Navajo I think influenced and so I got
the cultural appropriation going on
today and we all laughed everyone in the
diner here luck probably about 10 people
we laughed and there was another server
who said oh no I said well I think that
the Navajo now they they wear Calvin
Klein on the Levi's so we're fine
everyone laughed and the one girl goes
no that's not okay cultural
appropriation is not okay this is one
person by the way the girl who's wearing
the sweater tattoo sleeves total hipster
bleached hair you would expect to see at
a punk rock bar these are not
conservatives they're all laughing at
our cultural appropriation jokes this
one other server who's nice I like hers
no no that's not okay my wife god bless
her happy Anniversary sweetheart
looks down and I know what on his shaven
legs the girl who was offended at
cultural appropriation was unshaven like
so this is this is the the moral of the
story is look before you assume that
this person is mainstream if that's an
Aesop fable the one person who actually
was was invested in this idea of
cultural appropriation was offended was
the person the girl who didn't shave her
legs
I'm guessing Pitts was not wearing a bra
was definitely not wearing a bra so it's
important how many how many girls do you
know who don't shave their legs her pits
probably not very many how many do you
know on campus probably a lot how many
who go to the Grateful Dead concert
probably more and they grab the
headlines but even in this little spot
there's a little hit breakfast spot
everyone was laughing at the idea of
cultural appropriation and how silly it
was the only person who was making a
scene was the one with unshaven legs who
it was offensive that's where we are and
that's why it's important to push back
and point out the absurdity and laughs
because most America including liberals
including leftists okay it's important
that they're not all not all liberals or
social justice left it's mainstream in
the Democratic Party it's mainstream in
the media platform but it's not
mainstream in the United States so you
don't need to accept that you're among
the other ten people in the diner who do
shader like or maybe not well if you're
a guy it's a different situation we'll
get back to the I don't know how to
pivot from this with the dildos and the
shaved legs head that will be back
[Music]
you
okay everyone quiet down thanks for
coming to social justice anonymous here
on UT campus as you know the state has
now made it legal for people to exercise
their second Amendment rights here on
campus with concealed carry we need to
send them a message that this will not
stand and we need to do it in an
effective cogent way that communicates
our point of view do we have any ideas
I don't think we'll top that meeting
adjourned hey Jared what are you doing
shooting bad guys
with what where'd you get it
pfft nah c'mon state it more clearly so
our audience can hear hey our 15.com
that's better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good if they're the best
we're from air 15 accom Kapoor come on
you really make that sound didn't have
the budget for sound a bag with 150 from
where air 15.com hey how do you know
they're bad guys dirt roads in burkas
kaboom that's racist
[Music]
glad to be back up after this break we
will have Curt Schilling Curt Schilling
all talking about my cousin was saying
make sure you respect the man he's one
of the best players ever had no idea I
don't follow the baseball yeah just no
big deal no big deal I'm a man I'm a
grown-ass man and I don't follow
hobbies send your hate mail to Adnan Kay
Jared because he's the one who actually
really hates baseball and team sports
for I don't know watch it I don't know
why so we did this this piece last week
on Amy Schumer the rape situation at UCB
so there's been a lot doesn't happening
the news I want to get to the Trump
stuff well we'll talk with Kurt more so
about his run we'll talk with the Trump
with John Nolte on the Trump stuff did
this thing on Amy Schumer last week in
the rape situation of social justice
where your leftists who are encouraging
rape culture by being complicit with the
hashtag movements and not notifying the
proper authorities I think somewhere in
there I may have taken some jabs at Amy
Schumer's physical appearance that's
surprising doesn't sound like you it
doesn't sound like something I would do
it also I got some comments an email
saying hey hey why do you feel the need
to [ __ ] shame or fat shame why do you do
this it hurt with your audience here's
the thing there is no slut-shaming
culture there is no fat shaming culture
people need to understand this they
throw it out there because you make a
joke about Lena Dunham being
unattractive and fat the reason someone
might [ __ ] shaming me Schumer remember
she got so mad when a fan came up and
took a picture said hey spent the night
with Amy Schumer
but that's not the first time she heard
that and she's gonna how dare you call
someone you don't know a [ __ ] it's not
slut-shaming it's a reaction from the
public to someone who has made their
entire living off set your stopwatch
someone who portrays himself as a SWAT
her whole thing is I get so drunk I
don't remember who I was left with
my diaphragm fell out that's pretty much
hurt her stick I think she can be funny
sometimes but that is her bit that's her
act
it's like senior winces tonight only
it's a vagina
that's Amy Schumer's bit do you know
senior you don't even know senior winces
so it's a reaction by someone saying
okay you're portraying yourself as a
[ __ ] this is your stick I'm going to go
along with it and now I'm annoyed with
the sluttiness you don't get to be
offended that someone thinks you're
[ __ ] Lena Dunham Lena Dunham has
openly talked about and has stood before
dozens let's be happy not thousands and
I said you know our show was designed to
I really want to push this idea the
boundaries of what people think is is
traditionally beautiful okay do that but
you don't get to be offended when people
have the gall to insinuate that you are
not traditionally beautiful and it's
because you've made your career or like
a test holiday remember that oversized
model who we talked about Oh Lord
can't forget I don't I don't dislike
fact this isn't fat shaming it is a
reaction to someone demanding that you
praise their body saying hey hey look at
me I am proud of my body and people
saying well maybe maybe you shouldn't be
proud of your body it's a reaction to
you making a living off of your body
this is if amy schumer were were your
barista at Starbucks right you wouldn't
walk up there but listen here you little
Stay Puft Marshmallow looking [ __ ] you
wouldn't do that because you don't know
her but if she was at Starbucks saying
oh my gosh I slept with a bunch of guys
last night
testing hot material you'd probably say
hey your god my baristas kind of [ __ ]
and I knew that about my barista I heard
of that when her touching my cold brew
same thing with Lena Dunham listen by
the way with Lena Dunham if you my
criticisms with Lena Dunham are not
based on the unkempt self-admitted
filthy exterior it's everything that's
inside it is the soul of Lena Dunham
that I have a problem with it's just
easy - also it happens to be wrapped in
a package that it's all discussed none
of it is good so and no guy by the way
it's not because you're not
traditionally beauty is your like what a
guitarist a basis for fun who is in
desperate need of a beard no one is
interested in in someone like Lena
Dunham
and here's the deal what really bothered
me with a [ __ ] shaming and fat shaming
thing just because you feel as though
you're a more victimized class you don't
get to have the corner on it so a good
example is I was just at a mall recently
Lane Bryant they have one of these these
plus-sized models now and they have earn
real women dollars clothes for real
women is what they say don't act like
you're not marginalizing people so what
are they saying with this my wife's not
a real woman
my mom's not a real woman my
mother-in-law isn't a real woman nearly
every guy I know who's married to a real
woman is in fact married to a figment of
their imagination because these women
aren't plus-sized so they're simply
deciding to discriminate against women
who are smaller than them by the way
while we're talking about that I
guarantee you there are more real women
who are closer in size to runway models
or fashion magazine models than Tess
holiday and let's take it a step further
I guarantee you there are more real
women within the proper perimeters of
Health closer to the size of more
traditional models not saying that I
want to need to look like that but you
don't get to have the corner and
victimization because you chose to be
overweight that's what bothers me about
it and when you make a career on it it
is totally fair game and especially
because we have an obesity problem and
we have a diabetes problem in this
country I think when you cross that
realm of health it is within a fair
boundaries of criticism something else
same thing with diseases we've talked
about this listen I'm sorry mister that
you decided to have unprotected anal sex
with bearded bikers and a truck stop and
you got AIDS that's horrible
I wouldn't wish it on anybody who has
unprotected anal sex with bearded bikers
and truck stops
I wouldn't between the dirty needle use
I watched rent I know what I'm talking
about but you don't get to have the
corner on diseases aids get so Mike it's
a disease that gets so much more funding
than all of these cancers or type 1
diabetes that the kid didn't sign up for
just because you scream the loudest
whether it's with dildos on campus or
it's about being offended that someone
insinuated you aren't good-looking
doesn't mean that you deserve to have
the corner on victimhood
and that's my issue with it also I just
realize I don't like Lena Dunham
I find her incredibly unfunny I have
clarified my thoughts there clarifies do
you know what seriously though no it's
right no one listen if you see someone
like Lena Dunham in real life right you
go like I mean maybe she could shower
but that's unfortunate
but you don't you don't make a thing out
of it but when she says I'm beautiful
and people who don't declare me to be
beautiful are sexist now that's a
problem and you're almost morally
obligated to say you're not reality
check this so that's where it confuse
and why do you double down on it listen
I'm not doubling down on it I'm not
doubling down on fat shaming or
slut-shaming if you make a career off of
it and you thrust it in front of peoples
but you know what also have a problem
with it wrote about this professional
victimhood is America's fastest-growing
business that's why you have Shaun King
and Rachel Dolezal competing to be black
guys amy schumer and lena dunham ininin
female comics competing as to who was
raped more but never came forward to the
cops because it's the best way to get
your name in the headlines in the
absence of talent or wit and does assume
that the reason may be fatter down -
that does mean what's being fatter Amy
Schumer and all the muscle McCarthy
there's I meant to do it yeah
we have to go to a break here right
break we have Curt Schilling coming up
talking about running against Elizabeth
Warren and Trump stay tuned
[Music]
you
this month in her new comedy special Amy
Schumer's offended by everything so
letting up to me and he said I bet I'm
not the first guy to be here before I am
playing in a slide the joke you just did
what's funny how you slut-shaming me
what that's really offensive but aren't
you a comedian stay tuned for more
comedy on the cutting edge
[Music]
alright let me back with our guest who
is shaking his head already embarrassed
a little little quick quick inside
baseball here before we went live I
always say hey what's the best thing to
plug he said you don't need to plug
anything because he's Kurt freakin
Schilling Curt Schilling thank you for
being on the show sir it was terrible
well don't let your son see it because
it gets only more embarrassing we will
it's all on the youtube so Kurt with
little known fact he was we were the
first show he did after this controversy
that he had that blew up last time with
with ESPN and then everyone started
thank God everyone started having him on
and people realized hey this is this is
actually a guy who's making a lot of
sense now you may or may not you tell me
where I get it wrong run for president
in a few years and you more than likely
will run against Elizabeth Warren just
to embarrass her for her seat do I have
that right 1949 or some year before I
was born
yeah I'm contemplating that part and you
know if Hillary ends up somehow
criminally stealing an election then you
know maybe I might ramp up the White
House run I don't know if I want to get
involved I'm tired of watching people
sit around and talk and not actually do
anything and and because I I'm in danger
being one of those people so if I'm
gonna keep it up I'm gonna probably try
and step on that stage and go up against
my alpha
well the Land O'Lakes butter lady um you
know it's it's you're an accomplice gets
funny I talked about this when you came
up I don't follow baseball at all I
don't I'm not gonna lie about it my
cousin talked to me he actually coaches
college baseball he said do you realize
that you were talking you know Kurt is
I'm like yeah he's a great baseball
player he goes no no no you don't
understand
he's like top five top ten ever do you
understand he's like goes Wayne Gretzky
oh yeah sure when Gracie's like Gordie
Howe he goes he's that in baseball and
he was the people were infuriated that I
wasn't giving you your due so I am now
[Laughter]
my own freaking house so well yeah but
nobody is profits aren't appreciated in
their in their hometown
so you're accomplished there you you
work with the SPN you've done you've
done so much is it at the point now
would you have done this let's say if
you were still working with the network
do you think you would have felt
compelled to some people might say well
it's cuz he got canned for being
offensive so he has to you don't really
have to do anything at this point do you
of an insanely liberal bigoted a very
very racist group of people who
portrayed themselves to be anything
other than that the only sad part about
that was I love the people I work with
not the people I work for so I I think I
think watching you listening to
Braveheart on on the Patriot Channel
watching some Hannity watching some of
the everything that's going on I want to
be involved in talking about stuff that
matters and that moves the needle and I
think you've seen it with your show
where you have people go wow you know I
learned something I didn't know and it's
something that's fundamental as the
difference between a semi-automatic and
automatic weapon right awesome you know
that a great example for me is you know
Trump Trump's immigration policy is
basically allowed every left-of-centre
human being on the flag to call him a
racist which is so not true but anyway
silly when you bring up the point that
the last three major immigration reforms
that passed through our political system
all contain gigantic enormous amounts of
money to pay for a wall to be built and
it's never been built people don't know
that no and what it tells you is the in
the right neither one wants to build it
right I'm just want to be for everyone
wants to be against it as if it goes up
nobody has any close
more what's interesting that you you
know a couple of questions that does it
concern you that you know this week
Trump has kind of walked it back and
said he'll do something very similar to
Obama and George W Bush he seems to be
softening their the concern listen his
first his first stance which was
basically I'm gonna march down the
country and we're gonna kick every
single illegal alien out no matter what
is honorable Underwood I think a lot
like a lot of politicians he spoke
before he thought which if that's
possible then I'm gonna win a lesson
somewhere because I do that all the time
and this is kind of his MO and assistant
he's very emotional you can tell when
he's on his popular when he's not
mmm-hmm he gets emotional like everybody
else that cares about this stuff does
and he says things then and then the
people in the back of like oh come on
and he goes backstage and thinks you
should have said that right I think he's
looking for which is an actual process
not just a fixed immigration process but
one that's actually running right
there's a process no it's it's really
silly and I talked about this I said
listen if your immigration policy only
affects regardless of race gender
orientation illegal immigrants it can't
be racist and I say this
first-generation immigrant my mom
french-canadian learned the language
went through it so of all the criticisms
with Trump and we've talked about this
there are valid ones everyone has has
things that can be criticized Valley in
a valid way him being racist for wanting
to get rid of illegal aliens committing
crime is not one of them he wants to he
wants to extreme that illegals coming
into this country from nations and
harbor and and and are terrorists driven
wrong with that you know you were born
you know but we have a set of rules and
statutes and laws in this country that
for Boston 1776 has made us what we are
and contrary to what the left would have
you believe this is the greatest country
in the world I know they think we
shocked and you know they they're all
about their comrades and all the other
crap that they talk about but but with
the Constitution the bill right
all those things were written in very
clear precise plain English because they
knew idiots were going to go left and
try to misconstrue misinterpret and if
you read that if you read the documents
I mean it is it legal for someone who
doesn't live here legally to vote in any
election right number one you go to jail
the most of these other countries if you
just go there illegally Kurt Schilling
and I should not be allowed to go on
down to a booze cruise in Cancun and
elect their next leader that would be
absolutely fun we can know I would be a
fun weekend just going down there hey do
you want the love for between my Coronas
and what I don't know or hey sounds like
a good what do you do Prime Minister
your president shot me down for that yes
well you know it's it's it's funny that
you say that because people don't even
know the laws in the books in Mexico how
harsh they are for example even owning
waterfront property showing up to
disruptive anti-government protests
things that we here just take for
granted as basic fundamental human
rights are not civil rights in Mexico
just for being an immigrant even a legal
one number one and you have to prove
yourself a value to society a value
added to be a legal sense it in Mexico
yeah but the important thing to me as
you watch these idiots on YouTube the
guys that were interrupting the Trump
rally the other night that came on to
the interviews they were bitching
because asked right as opposed to when
you go to liberal protests like Occupy
or pro-union protests just for showing
up and disagreeing you get the crap
kicked out of you because they leave the
place violent and they leave the place
filthier than when they found it whereas
conservatives they pick up after
themselves remember however we was
saying the Tea Party regardless of they
were like oh it's gonna be violent and
they were they were actually volunteers
cleaning up with pokey sticks
well here's your next video next YouTube
video go to an Occupy go to a liberal
rally and just like keep doing the
college camp campuses ask these people
why they're protesting yeah it's
happening related to reality well
actually some of them do because it
professionally hired to be there
protesting why are you here well cuz the
SC I use checks cashed that's not that's
why he's been pours whole life he hasn't
done anything
and he's vacationed in the Soviet Union
what part of that do you identify well
now he has a third house up there up to
Lake Vermont what shot listen he was
fighting us I don't begrudge anyone for
doing that it is just the blatant
hypocrisy I think people understand that
with with Donald Trump with really a lot
of the the Republican candidates I think
Carly Fiorina did a very good job of
exposing it because she's looked behind
the curtain she's super wealthy and she
was saying these people are pulling the
strings in an unfair way people like
Bernie Sanders the problem you have is
them trying to really rig the system
against people United States trying to
be successful and they're successful
ironically at the expense of you and I
on the teat of the government his whole
life that's the issue and I think a lot
of people like you talked about I hope
to see you make some headway with what
you do because a lot of people even on
the right they're professional Talking
Heads they're longtime politicians they
get a job on cable news and their
opinion is about as valid as Bernie
Sanders well they're terrified of the
establishment going away and by the way
Bernie Sanders for all his love of the
Soviet Union
I would like for him to travel to the
Soviet Union as a peasant instead of as
a tourist rose it's a different country
when you're one of the billion that that
has to feed the government yeah but yeah
listen what everything you think you
want to understand about how screwed up
this country is a woman like Sarah Palin
a woman like Carly Fiorina there they
are pariahs they are just vilified and
scrutinized and their families are
ripped apart and their kids are ripped
apart they're strong type-a women who
have done something and achieve
something and and the left destroys them
and
as the kind of woman you want to lead to
come quick Wow
right yeah but you see she didn't finish
the word I don't know if we have to FCC
that country lead the country country
and I don't know if that was but you
know a good example my wife is the exact
to me my wife manages a multi-million
dollar company she's constantly working
she's very type A and I find that
unbelievably attractive and a woman
she's also very warm and and soft and I
know we'll make a great mother when we
when we do that you know for example who
do you think let's just get rid of the
physical appearance because that's not
fair who is more attractive to a man a
Carly Fiorina or or Lena Dunham eating a
cake on the toilet I assume it's because
it last night about the German economy
and misusing every possible phrase you
can do it she tried she tried to sound
intelligent and sounded really stupid
and trying to do so
yeah it's dumb and Rosie O'Donnell are
two reasons for every human on this
planet to vote for Trump they both said
they leave the country yeah but Alec
Baldwin I think said that when Bush won
re-election they never follow through on
it
I'll talk to me the promise to Sharpton
oh no they never go to Mexico they want
to go to Canada and Gavin McGinnis did a
great video on that on really what they
mean in Canada like you can't go to
French Canada because they're racist and
discriminatory against everyone no one
wants to go to Western Canada because
there's nothing really there talking
about Toronto and yeah exactly and I
don't think they'll understand that
someone like Lena Dunham or Rosie
O'Donnell they say the wrong thing and
they can be jailed in Toronto there's no
not anymore he lives out there in Torch
Lake and Trevor Wright
but as you can get let's just vilify an
entire nation of people before we go to
a break
Kurt we'll bring you back after this and
I am half Canadian but I'll tell you
what mr. Schilling is not wrong but send
your hate mail to him stay tuned we'll
be right back with more Kurt Schilling
[Music]
more about to catch the news just in the
nick of time with Nick Nolte Washington
area warm Abe Lincoln freed the pickles
I'm not voting mr. Brigance
qualification that was news in the nick
of time with Nick Nolte
[Music]
glad to be back our guest does not like
our dancing but screw him because he
thinks what he can he can throw he
thinks he can throw he can throw a ball
and he has a right to tell us what to do
how dare you Curt Schilling oh my god
that was well this is this is the show
see if we list lower expectations every
time hey speaking of which so you you
know you've been going back and forth my
producer tell us a story about how
you've not gay Jared and your personal
telephone no I was telling him he sent
me a text and he said hey this is steven
crowder producer at not gage yard or
something like that like Wow did I say
that I don't think even said that so
Jared I'll wait for you okay oh this
could get this could get nc-17 yeah Wow
yeah just don't show the pictures
pictures says Mr Schilling this is
steven crowder producer at not gay Jared
Oh see if we can book you blah blah blah
sorry and I was telling him earlier so
well I saved it now what here's my phone
in my contacts he's not gay Jared yeah
hey so what's gonna happen if I do
decide to run for office my first public
press convert to my phone ring and it'll
sing not gay t right across the top and
I will immediately get letters from LGBT
and every don't forget the QA AIP
yeah whatever well you were saying
because you're actually pretty socially
liberal we talked about you in the last
pro on the last program you're socially
moderate anyway you're certainly not in
any way would be considered homophobic
of course that's the attack now that you
may run for a state Senate seat you said
when this happened there was this hit
piece written about you either was
Boston Boston general balls and Boston
Globe and you were saying was it was it
your vet who is a friend very dear
friend okay very dear friend and she is
of the homosexual persuasion and he said
she wrote you a letter she is a she that
she called me she's a very dear friend
and she called me and said she said she
was so upset because she didn't
understand how someone who could legally
do and write what they wrote knowing
full well none of it was true
and and you know an incredibly brilliant
woman like I said a very dear friend and
I had to explain to her and I was like
you know don't worry about it bleh she's
like no no no I want to write some
letter you know but that's you know I'm
sure you rented this as well I tell my
kids don't ever try and live your life
to make people that don't know you like
you so good good you know it's even
amidst how caustic you can be and this
show can be that is actually very good
advice well but here's the thing
socially liberal I'm a Christian I
believe in in in in the bonds of
marriage and all but but it's not my
place nor do I believe it's the federal
government's place right involved in
that stuff let this step we are smart
people let the state's decide who what
when why and where they want to do
things right I don't need anyone in BC
to debate on who should pee and whose
bathroom well yeah the thing is with
that is because there was a city
ordinance right in Charlotte and the
state had to come in and say well listen
you can't you can't file these suits or
complaints again businesses if they
don't want you know [ __ ] in the in
the ladies room so there's a little more
to it but I agree with you you know what
you just said about states that's always
what I mean I don't think marriage is a
fundamental human right you know we're
not talking about civil rights I don't
think it's a human right it's a contract
into which two people enter willingly
and states constantly have the right to
determine the ins and outs and the
nuances of those and I think what you
said is perfectly fine and it's
perfectly tenable along side also if a
bed-and-breakfast in a state doesn't
want to cater to a gay wedding they
don't have to well but it's almost now
now we're getting to a place where
they're the left wants to make it legal
that they would have to examine that he
is absolutely terrifying ground now I
talked about running for the Senate and
a lot of people in this you know I've
said something about you know what's
your stance on gay marriage and X Y and
I've tried to explain these people
assuming a senator is someone who
represents his constituents or her
constituents in DC takes the concerns of
the people that vote and live in the
state that they represent and brings
them to DC and I think the classic a
really good case is Elizabeth Warren
and a lot of her friends are all about
free public education they want free
college tuition and I ran the numbers
and it's stat first when we have a
thirty eight billion dollar budget in
math and you're talking about an extra
three point I think it's or fifteen
point three billion every four years for
the twenty nine public schools at school
one hundred ninety one thousand students
now add on top of that how many kids are
gonna go to college you wouldn't
normally go but hey it's free right and
you've got a runaway train and many of
them shouldn't be and it's nothing wrong
with that ABS absolutely but here's the
problem when you take that national
you're looking at I think the number was
1.3 trillion dollars every four years
for the get and that and again how many
hundreds of thousands of more kids are
gonna go to college because it's free
not because they want to go but hey it's
four more years of life I want to pay
for anything
so let me laser it on this because
you're talking about it and now you're
getting very technical you're throwing
some numbers out there which I think
will probably surprise a lot of people
let's say you go up against Elizabeth
Warren and you beat her worse than her
people scalped other Native Americans
before we ever got here let's say that
happens what does Curt Schilling do what
does that look like an office what's the
first thing you do the first thing again
it's not that it's not an office for me
to decide what I'm doing the Senate a
Senate seat is that your job is to
represent the people of Massachusetts
what do they want done what was their
number one priority is it immigration
because the governor handles the the
state budget and the fiscals
the financial world that is
Massachusetts and I think Charlie Baker
has done a good job he's a very dear
friend I think a lot of people on the
right are really pissed then he's gone
more Center but he's the most liked
governor in the country so he's doing
something right right but the Senate is
a much it's a it's a bigger picture
thing right I mean I'm not gonna go and
have a bathroom law changed in
Massachusetts I'm going to take the
constituents of Massachusetts concerns
to Washington DC and that's where I
think first of all I don't know how much
you know me but I have absolutely no
idea being the fly in the I'm not no
problem being the fly in the ointment
I'll sit in a room full of people who
say yeah I think we should do this and
I'll say well [ __ ] I don't think we
should well you know what that's when
they I know you're Trump guy but you
know who's done that better than anyone
and has the highest approval rating of
people who voted for him is Ted Cruz
he's basically said I'm going in and
what I'm mostly going to do is say no
and that's how what he's done and well
hopefully so so Curt Schilling would
would be similar to Ted Cruz maybe in
that room but she had to get stuff done
and if you look at Elizabeth Warren's
record she's got five or six bills that
are in introduction she coached she
sponsored them she didn't actually offer
them I know she got three three things
definitely passed she got a day to
recognize the 2013 Red Sox as world
champions which they were anyway she got
a day to recognize the New England
Patriots a Super Bowl champion well we
have to let you go wrap it up with two
seconds she got she got a bill pass to
get a chair put it in the house building
to represent POWs well okay so there you
go but I tell you what come back when
there's more developing I would love to
see you run if only for the
entertainment value and we will cover it
as closest can Curt Schilling legend and
good guy to have on the show stay tuned
everybody will have who do we have next
you know I don't know
you
Hoppa wants you to believe that he's
looking out for the best interests of
every American and he's asking for your
vote but as you learned last week he
doesn't ask for everything like noodles
which he steals is that a guilty face of
one or these dogs he forced to fight for
their life in his underground fighting
ring doesn't seem like he asked for
their permission
it's a far cry from cheese's yeah what
about his newly announced vice
presidential candidate Tim Kaine why is
he always interrupting professional
broadcast
doesn't he have better things to do with
his time and what's the real story
between him and not gay Jared I guess if
you don't ask he'll never tell Superman
I think not the choice is becoming clear
America
Harper unfit unqualified and unamerican
[Music]
all right we're glad to be back with our
next guest I put on a nice shirt because
this man is an Olympian
he's classing up the joint glad to have
him here pole vaulting medalist Sam
Kendricks thank you for being with us
sir well don't don't admit that because
that could be more harmful to your PR so
the PR side of your career than anything
else you would will fully admit what was
it was a fish hook a fish because he was
fishing not my producer for digging up
all these days yes exactly this is what
we do to make up for our lack of actual
dance moves exactly which I would
imagine you probably have better by the
way people listening at Sam Kendricks
because you're an Olympian you're an
athlete so it translates before we go
into it I want to show this clip I
didn't see this a lot on on a lot of
mainstream media out there I found it my
dad particularly found it and it's a
it's a heart string tugger this is Sam
Kendricks amidst one of his his runs at
the Olympics in in pole vaulting and the
national anthem was playing let's just
play it it's better than I can describe
and we'll come back
[Music]
you
we won't roll the whole clip so you can
go see that ladder with credit come to
see the whole thing from start to finish
for those listening to rest really was
running up pole in hand which by the way
terrifies me those things oh yeah it
looks like such a weapon and drops it
here's the national anthem playing and
sort of you oriented yourself to find
out was playing in and stood there at
attention I know you're an Army
reservists was this was this instinct
were you moved but obviously it's it's
it's something that's that's rare it
hasn't really occurred before and what
was it the property to do that well it's
kind of second nature to do that sort of
thing
any service man or woman in a similar
situation would dropped we dropped into
a position of attention whenever the
star-spangled banner' revelry or retreat
was playing usually they only play it at
the beginning of baseball games on base
at morning and evening or on special
occasions but you basically you stop
what you're doing you render respect
into the flag mine was just a little bit
in a more of a more tense situation so
I'm gonna say if that's the case he was
be you're probably inside you're a
little pissed like what are they doing
this is the middle of my Olympic run
this shouldn't be happening now no no
you tuned all of these outside stressors
out turn out don't even look at the
crowd you don't listen to the booing in
the stands it's just you just what you
do to focus but sometimes you can't
focus through what's happening it's
close to your heart and so when there's
when the national anthem starts to play
okay simply what is my first instinct
find my position of attention and find
the tallest flag tall one Dumbo Tron now
really you're supposed to fix the
raising flag but it was my first time in
the stadium so I don't know where it was
right do a couple facing movements with
just perfectly fine nor find the correct
flag in order to face it and run at the
correct expects right well jeez I mean
for Grenaa Lada its it makes me wonder
well what are those other Olympians do
and this guy was in the middle Paul in
hand and stopped and looked him going
way I was like what about the rest of
you guys I guarantee you this song was
playing while they were up there did it
did it because because he won bronze and
did it affect it all your your score did
you get to run again how does that work
for people who who
no and for for reference most people
don't know the pole vault competition
just like any field event has a warmup
period and this particular instance
happened during the warmup period when
my friend Michelle Carter was being
presented her gold medal um you know
generally any any service man or woman
say I need to be more attentive and have
my head on a swivel but like I said I
really need to focus those things out so
when Star Spangled Banner having played
it was just an ad running down the
runway and everyone got quiet and
star-spangled banner' start to play I
turn around I mean did not affect affect
my competition other than I wasted a
little bit of energy but that's we
trained for years and years to have
excess of that yeah I can imagine so you
were in Brazil right now Brazil is an
incredibly nationalistic country for
people who don't know when foreign team
does going whether it's fights or soccer
they actually chant that they will kill
them like this is a very common
Brazilian chant did they embrace your
American patriotism or were they were
they a little bit perturbed yes I was
really very well-received by the
Brazilian people just by on a basis that
I know I'm a friendly ambassador I know
they're their best bear best vaulter his
name is Chicago he was actually the
champion the gold medal it's the first
gold medal from Brazil for that whole
Olympics well and I'm good friends with
him I show I was I was the best
ambassador I could be when he said his
personal best for the gold for the gold
medal and if you can just go on my
Twitter Instagram you can see all these
Brazilians have been commenting and say
hey thank you come back to Brazil which
I thought was very sweet um we
definitely did see that certain focus on
their nationality in the Coppola
competition my French friend was
actually booed on the runway and on the
Olympic podium and I don't think they
realized that's not supposed to happen
at track meets and especially at the
Olympics you're really supposed to
uphold that Olympic spirit um but I you
have to take it with a grain of salt but
they're nice not necessarily chanting
against you but so much for their guy
and it's really just I'm for my guy I'm
against the other guy right yeah they do
it that way now that your friend this is
not the person who robbed Ryan Lochte
correct different different Brazilian oh
no I'm kidding I'm kidding I appreciate
it you're such a good ambassador going
there and obviously you know as polite
as can be classing up this joint yeah it
is one thing
if someone like you for example when we
have Olympics in United States if you
yelled out or your fans you thought that
you were going to kill them or the
Brazilians or booed them it would be
national news it's just a part of their
culture there they almost always cheer
their guy even if their guy is is is not
a very savory character like Americans
you can lose their favor really quickly
right people now are not super thrilled
with Ryan Lochte in Brazil it doesn't
matter you're the Brazilian guy they
cheer you but I did notice that with
yours I didn't hear any boos so so
that's good very patriotic very
nationalistic and they're gonna cheer
for that flag it doesn't matter whose
chest it's on so that's just the way
they are Americans they see they see
through the veil when they watch TV they
don't know me but there's no USA's on my
chest and they're gonna be cheering for
me which I'm really thankful for it's
true although I tell you what they
wouldn't cheer for you as much if you
weren't such an upstanding young man
like you are now I mean in a good
example in the United States like if you
watch the NHL or fighting is very
international or soccer they will boo
their own countrymen if they think that
they're jackasses so I would give you
more credit it's not as because II had a
flag on your chest I think it moved a
lot of people because you know they felt
like okay here's someone who we want
representing our country yeah you put in
a very unique situation very quickly
when you put the USA colors on you put
that uniform on and you go to the
Olympics to compete for your country
because you're not necessarily competing
for yourself like I am here in
Switzerland you're competing for your
country doesn't necessarily how much
alway and how well you do but so much as
how you represent yourself and who you
came there to represent now you were
telling me right before we came on that
this is the Olympics happen right at the
end of your track season so this is
really busy for you and now are you
you're still an army reservist right yes
correct I'm my reserve unit I served
with them monthly and I studied up to
date on my training they're actually a
Millington Tennessee and this is the
ending the closing of the summer track
and field season it's very condensed
these next three weeks where all the
high-level athletes are going to go to
perform in order to really garner those
points in their world Grand Prix that's
without getting into too much detail
that's basically like the high level
track and field circuit yeah well I've
seen for me as a simple tonight I don't
know about you Jared I thought the
Olympics was
that was limping track and field's
happens they don't we don't really
follow it outside of that so how do you
mean how do you maintaining that
schedule I mean you know you're in the
Army Reserves you got this crazy season
with the Olympics now you're in
Switzerland how is that possible or are
you just gonna be it is there gonna be a
doping test that comes out and says well
that's why he was a cyborg appreciate
that kind of humor but you say as a
civilian I compete as a net and now as a
reservist I do all oh I think we're
losing him a little bit because he's
over there in Switzerland just because
you're over there you're over there in
Europe see they don't they're not as on
to the internet as we are yet here let
me hear you again sir I think I missed
you and try to really up there standing
on the world stage I'm at the Olympics
is where everybody watches but the the
world Grand Prix is were really athletes
make their bones but not necessarily
compete for the country sure well I
would imagine that's same thing you know
like what's with World Wrestling
Championships or like you know Kayla
Harrison world Judo Championships you
look at some and sometimes you have
these people who perform really well on
that stage and they dismiss it by just
that much in the Olympics do they do
they carve out anything for you you know
in the the Army Reserves they say like
okay listen this guy's an Olympian he's
going to the Olympics he doesn't need to
do the full pull-ups push-ups routine we
let's let's make him exempt from that do
all the other stuff but let's not feed
him for the mess hall and let's let him
do his training and still serve the
country are you just another another
soldier when you're out there well as an
officer I certainly do things in tandem
in order to stay up today well on my
training would not I always have to have
that maximum PT score just to be a good
representative for my unit and those men
below me sure but my unit is given me a
lot of leeway in order to travel in
order because they know that I'm also
representing the army you know I say
it's army wherever I go they know that
this is we want we want you to grow a
great image so we can use that image in
the future that's part of my job right
absolutely yeah I think it's important
to be able to note I mean that's why we
covered this story on the website it's a
lottery with credit com i really suggest
people go watch the full video it is
touching the first time you watch it
you're going like wow this is a moment
of genuine just unbridled emotion and
patriotism and sometimes I think we look
at these athletes we see them on TV and
we think we think of them as robots so
Sam Kendricks at Sam Kendricks we're
glad to have you representing our
country representing our military thanks
for coming on brother we really
appreciate it I really appreciate you
taking time to deal with me and my
Comcast know Comcast upon sir for you
moving forward you don't know you don't
want to just narrow it down to Verizon
or god forbid sprint so Comcast yeah
just say European Internet yeah yeah
that's all whew mobile over here there
you go exactly
Sam Kendricks we'll be back everybody
stay tuned and go watch that video he's
worth your time
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Delilah's show Emily
you're on the air thanks for calling you
hi my god it's a big fan I can't believe
I'm on here oh that's okay sweetheart
it's exciting when you're on radio yes
okay so I didn't know who to call but I
have a problem with my boyfriend now we
all have problems in relationships the
key is to be grateful for what we have
yeah and I feel like we've always had
connection so maybe you could help me of
course I'll always do my best so it
started after our five month anniversary
where I thought that maybe he was
cheating on me
sometimes there's always enough love to
go around right but they were all
founded and I realize those was just me
being paranoid
now see you don't need to jump to
conclusions it's more important that you
always love yourself right but then he
started locking me in a closet for days
on end and beating me without mercy what
was that in the closet and we beat me
with a bamboo rod that he picked up on a
business trip from Bangkok well
sometimes it's unfortunate but one of
life's little ironies that we hurt the
people we love most
you must love you a lot so Emily what
can I do for you tonight well the reason
I'm calling is because he blocked 911 oh
I was hoping you could call the cop oh
well I can't do that because I have a
job to do but of course I wish you the
best and I can soothe your worries with
the wondrous sounds of Alison Krauss you
take care now
you can speak right to
[Music]
[Music]
oh we're back hopper growling at the
dancing we did we need to dance while
feeding him like turkey just like you
conditioned his mind sardines
we are back that was Sam Kendricks
coming up after the break we're going to
have and McIlhenny lady I'm back to my
my previous shirt had to class it up for
the Olympics and people go yes it was a
pre-taped because he was in Sweden
dummies but we are live now there was an
attack in Belgium look likes it looks
like it might have just been a gas leak
so our thoughts are with those folks out
there I'm going to really quickly read
Jerry hey Dean listen alright my
therapist had me drop these boundary
things like batteries that you're
honest-to-goodness you're not respecting
it so what I have to do is I'm supposed
to tell you you know which boundaries
you're crossing when the Queen
I don't know how many more times it has
to happen
I didn't think he's going to call me
about that I mean listen we're always
glad to have Monty's a great guest
people love him but this is a stacked
week curt schilling Sam Kendricks and
McIlhenny John Nolan oh I know yeah
right now I have to read the results the
results from the poll earlier I asked
what do you think of Donald Trump's
recent immigration comments about a
thousand of you answered and it's split
right down the middle 31% said
disappointed 31% said you love it and
38% said the media lied about it all
exclamation exclamation I don't know
that the media lied about this one I
don't and I I don't know exactly where
Donald Trump was going with his plan but
I think people again just people need to
be honest about it
praise the man where you can and still
think critically where you have to and
if you were on board with never amnesty
getting rid of illegal immigrants he's
going to deport them I think if you
you're being honest right now you know
that's not the case and maybe listen
maybe this is him making a deal like he
said ask for something greater yeah and
then just allow it to scale back maybe
he planned all along to do this pivot
and far be it for me to say that isn't
smart politics speaking of politics we
have this later leader of the populist
alternative for Germany party I can't
pronounce her name froak Petri I think
she talked about gun control in Germany
and she said many people are
increasingly feeling unsafe every
law-abiding citizen should be in a
position to defend themselves their
family and their friends we all know how
long it takes until the police can get
to a scene especially in sparsely
populated areas she said this we have it
at ladder was credit calm talking about
how she was in favor of people arming
themselves with guns and self-defense
devices following a series of violence
violent attacks here last month you know
it's one of the ironies of the world
that the Germans seem to make some of
the best guns but they don't really get
to use them
that is said think about Signum his
German right his Sigmund I know Walters
German author isn't then in any o'clock
Austrian Austrian well I don't say
German people get really mad about that
the st. mo I mean they all have the same
policies that are on there yeah well
they are the same policies so they make
and they fine-tune these fantastic
pistols that much of the rest of the
world uses and they can't use it to
defend themselves this is an important
point when people get mad and I said
well there's no free speech in Canada
and so what do you mean there's no free
I mean there is no free speech in Canada
there is no free speech in Europe it's
not protected
we had Christopher Titus on who said
well can you give an example of tyranny
well this is an example of tyranny with
Germany in it let me explain this
tyranny isn't always Hitler takes your
guns away
it isn't always Minh takes your guns
away that's not what tyranny necessarily
is let's go back to him in the United
States right with Church of England
let's go back to taxation without
representation let's boil that down what
did it mean it meant that they were
paying into a system that they were
supporting a political system where they
don't even have a voice they weren't
represented and that was the real reason
that was a big reason anyway for the
American Revolution that was true it was
tyrannical enough that they wanted to
put a tax on their breakfast drink of
choice so let's let's not act as though
they'd be tolerating everything that's
going on today
so those necessarily have to be Hitler
well how is this tyranny in Germany well
let me tell you how you have the
selected few the elitists the Angela
Merkel's who are deciding what's good
for the collective their their duty
their job their is to represent the
collective really the duty here in the
United States is to to protect the
Constitution and the natural rights
thereof but that's not how it is
necessarily in Europe they don't have a
First Amendment they don't really have a
Second Amendment so the selected few the
elite are deciding what's best for the
collective and they're doing it against
the will of the collective at this point
with the immigration with a lot of their
policies and they're doing it while
disallowing individuals from protecting
their own rights so let me let me ask
you is this tyranny when people said no
no we don't we don't want an influx of
immigrants we don't want that we didn't
really get to vote on I don't know how
we feel about this boom there in your
back yard and all of a sudden you have a
record crime soaring rape and the
government isn't doing anything about it
because they're muzzled and they have to
be politically correct so they're Sharia
Courts popping up next year Walgreens
Shareef yes
popping right up now you think was bad
when they burned down the CVS in
Baltimore oh man right next to there it
can't get worse right next to there
right ed they have some Imam saying
divorce divorce divorce and some woman's
destitute it's pretty rough out there
it's a rough scene so immigrants coming
in crime people didn't say yes to this
the representatives the people who tax
without giving a voice to its citizenry
have decided you know what we're going
to do this and now the citizens are at
risk and that government is barring its
own citizens from protecting themselves
so you could find yourself in Germany
right now in an area where a bunch of
former Isis fighter slash refugees have
settled down there raping your women
they're not abiding by any kind of
Western civilization laws by Western by
European laws let's call it Western
civilization let's put under the
umbrella because I know people will get
mad and talk about sort of dividing laws
between different countries they're not
abiding by any laws that we know and and
care about in Western civilization
they're in your backyard they're raping
they're committing crimes they have
their own system of laws and the
government tells you no no no no no no
you don't have the right to protect
yourself
that's tyrannical they don't need to go
house to house and take all of your guns
away
they've already weakened you they've
already removed your god-given right to
protect yourself and your family
that's tyrannical enough and that's what
you're seeing in Germany and that's what
that's why you're seeing this uprising
in Europe you're seeing people
developing the spine that Americans have
had for a long time just a little bit
just a little bit with brexit just a
little bit with people like this in
Germany saying no no you can't import
rape yuji's and tell us that we can't
protect ourselves no wait this is a
fundamental a mammoth change in a
mindset in Europe like France banning
the burqini listen I'm not saying you
should ban the bikini but they don't
have a First Amendment the point there
and we wrote about it on the website is
the cultural shift to people saying you
know what if they don't want to
assimilate if these people are coming
over here our governments are going to
welcome them here and they don't want to
become a part of a first world country
now we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to step down on this that's a big change
and it's tyrannical enough and people
are waking up to it
speaking of which Europe and McIlhenny
coming up to talk Hillary and fracking I
love her she's just adorable
[Music]
fast forward to the Year 2022 - okay
thank you so much for applying to Platte
Lou and McDonald mr. Lochte yeah that's
right and you are applying for an
internship position correct
totes okay well your resume is nothing
less than impressive it says here that
you are fully trained in Microsoft suite
that's great can type 124 words a minute
Wow
also that you have been to the moon
that's right three times and back
correct incredible it also says that
you're a member of Mensa as well as the
Big Brain Society do I have that right
two cards it also says that you are head
of an accredited university yep a former
senator you know it as well as worked
for an undercover federal agent for
eight years abroad in Europe but I
didn't even know I also have your press
release of when you saved a small
Ethiopian child from a tree kid was
scared did my part as well as
single-handedly ended the Haiti
earthquake got long arms wasn't hard
this is nothing short of stellar Oh
finally it also says here that you once
beat Michael Phelps in the 200 meter
that's sure that happened once
okay mr. Lochte I find this hard to
believe
[Music]
[Music]
back with this next guest she's been on
the show a couple of times and and
Gosnell movie.com of course is her big
project that everyone needs to pay
attention to one of the biggest
crowdfunding campaigns of all time she's
worked on frack nation she's a wonderful
friend of the show I think stuff and
McIlhenny thank you for being back it's
good to be here Thank You Steven no
we're glad to have you I was just
telling her off air her husband filum is
fantastic love the guy but he's usually
the one who calls me when there's a
project and he leaves a voicemail I can
understand you and I can never
understand your husband on the phone
it's one of my ears and it it sounded
like this ah I swear to you that the
voice sounded like Oh bye
and I was like I get back to this later
and I filed it and I forgot about it so
I apologize listen I mean and I love the
way you describe you you say his name by
the way I have to say that it sounds
like some kind of a throat infection you
know it's like dream do the Lima film
it's either failing or feelable that
doesn't make any sense
failing or filum it's all good listen
Salem as an a Salem you can't expect me
to understand this plus I'm half
Canadian so I'll get it wrong anyway
it's all good water we have both of you
on some time to get because it's like a
sitcom waiting because I can do the
translation exactly I could do the
translator Lee or Steven your your
listeners should check out a video it's
gone fire love to Irish rowers who won a
silver in the Olympics and their
interview anyone could find it very very
easily but if you think my husband's
difficult to understand you should check
these guys out it's really worth looking
at and I swear to you guys it's it's a
genuine interview with them on a
national broadcaster in Ireland and it
is just classic they're brothers by the
way
anyway that's just a side note is there
like a hierarchy in Ireland because I
had a friend who was English and when he
watched we were watching some fight -
actually Conor McGregor's from Ireland a
big star right now we were watching some
fights and there's a fighter from
Liverpool and he just started laughing
his ass off because he thought it was
the funniest accent and I to me I could
kind of understand the difference but I
didn't realize that people from London
maybe he was from Manchester just
crapped on people from Liverpool to the
degree that they did well there's a
strong accent from different places so
in Ireland Cork is it's a specific
category cork and Kerry very very strong
accents but obviously you have a
particular issue with Tyrolean okay so
you have so much that you you you work
on you you and Salem are so prolific
recently you did so a Hillary Clinton
situation you were talking about as
actors depositions so basically and
anyone can find it online Clinton emails
on film and what we did was Judicial
Watch had managed to be able to depose a
lot of Hillary Clinton's staff these
depositions were recorded and filmed
however Clinton's and lawyers were able
to have the video of those depositions
which Cheryl Mills and whom Abaddon etc
to have the videos suppressed so what we
decided to do our phantom decided to do
and was to get the transcripts of those
depositions and hire actors here in
Hollywood and to basically recreate the
depositions and they're available online
they're on YouTube about half a million
people have watched so far and so check
them out you can find whom in Abaddon
you can find Cheryl Mills and Steve
Mullen unbelievable the testimony
unbelievable stuff so we did that we
crowdfunding it again as you know Steven
were very fond of crowdfunding we like
the idea of having the the public say
they want stuff that remain stream media
won't bother doing so you know $52,000
came in from over a thousand people and
we're super grateful for that because I
think it's a its history worth recording
and we're living we're living through
this quite extraordinary history every
day with new revelations so I think it
was worthwhile doing and for anyone it's
there forever they can how are you able
taking it down how are you able to cast
that and I have to imagine that Lena
Dunham turned down the Hillary Clinton
role pretty quickly isn't that
shocker most extraordinary shocker yeah
love that girl and well you know
actually with with a we have some
stories we have some stories you know we
had people you know because obviously I
was here in in in LA you have you know
every time you go for a meal like any
word are you gonna get your hair done
are you get anything John here the
person is not the job they say they do
you know that right yes so it's like
they're a hairdresser slash actor
voiceover actor mime are just singer and
you know want to run their own band or
whatever so there's no a lot of people
and I don't wanna make fun of them
actually because I think it's a really
great thing people try to you know to
perform in the arts and whatever so
there's a lot of people here who'd
really like to act so when you put out a
casting call you get a huge response and
we did get a huge response and then what
would happen was we would make it really
clear we're like do you know what this
is about do you understand what we're
doing here this is the verbatim
testimony of these depositions and what
suddenly happened Steven shocker just
blow me down with a feather here people
said oh I don't want even agree with
that oh I wouldn't do that yeah this is
turning down a good day's work
you know doing the thing that they
really want to do however it's worth
saying that the actors who did turn up
were fabulous and not all of them by the
way were conservatives there were you
know really good people open-minded
people who felt that this was important
and wanted to do it so we were you know
in the end it actually was quite easy to
find people and we got great people and
the performances are just amazing yeah
why I would imagine you have some people
trying to go off-book like I can't be
controlled by a director man no no this
is direct word testimony well maybe
that's what you say okay you're going
did you have any luck getting any any
Dwarfs to play healer clinks we've had
we've trouble with hire dwarves rent a
[ __ ] calm and they denied us because I
said we might use it for untoward
purposes I'm like your rent a [ __ ]
calm what purpose could there be
luckily none of the people that we were
trying to represent are actually midgets
so that kind of healthy Clinton is close
that's what you could they prefer little
truth okay all right luckily I've never
been up that close with her except for I
have to say that yesterday in my
neighborhood she was somewhere here in
the in Hollywood's and in whose house
was she in not Justin Bieber know which
is the one and
jet bill bill bill yeah Justin
Timberlake cuz Leo Ducati I was gonna
host them but he had the scandal but was
it Malaysian embezzlement so I was
driving yesterday morning I was driving
my husband to the airport he's giving a
speech about fracking tonight in Canada
and I'm on the way to the airport
thinking this is bizarre this is like
just makes no sense at all it took us
forever I thought we were gonna miss the
flight and of course I come back and
meet a neighbor and say what was that
all about
Oh Hillary Clinton is in the
neighborhood so it's like okay that
makes sense yes
there's thats hillary clinton that's her
security and that's her army of
pharmaceutical representatives to inject
sorry not to feed the conspiracy yes yes
the least of her problems is any kind of
an epileptic disorder believe me so
that's not locally run with here but
it's fun so okay so you did this that
was the reaction it's done it's done
really well you had the same situation
when you did it with them with Michael
Brown right when pregnant yeah would you
also by the way it's online for anybody
who wants to watch that Ferguson the
play is on YouTube and a lot of people
have watched already and it's it's
amazing and in fairness you know Salem
did an incredible job and it's really
worth watching you know and particularly
this summer with all the awful things
that have happened you know the d'lai
hands up don't shoot that that lie needs
to be exposed for what it is and it
really does and so Ferguson goes a
certain way to doing that and I think
it's really important I mean it reminds
me that I don't know if you saw you two
when they were on their world tour we
got a friend of ours brought us to the
show here in LA and it was you know it's
it's Bono so you know you can expect
what you expect but midway in the show
midway in the show and one of the big
things about the stage was that this big
long sort of platform that went all the
way down you know along the audience
whatever a really long thing was kind of
their special thing and they projected
images on screen and stuff but their big
moment was bono walking like 300 yards I
mean seriously this was a really long
platform with his hands up saying hands
up hands up don't shoot hands up don't
shoot hands up don't shoot don't eat
that album and he did that and he did
that in that world tour
and would have traveled the globe
telling and spreading that lie apart
Michael Brown about that you know I
think it's very sad the man died but he
you know the circumstances in which he
died were not well it just disappears as
the problem like corn Gaines we were the
only ones to actively cover it when it
happened to go away ha-haaa ii what is
going on here other people caught on
then we were the only ones to run the
video afterward of her traffic stops
where it was a clear-cut case of child
abuse the police are saying hey buddy
can you come with us we're gonna have to
get the car towed they're gonna try and
kill you we were not trying to kill you
buddy were your friends you gonna have
to kill me believe ya someone's gonna
say this impression is racist that's how
she sounded and then she got her wish
she was using her child as a human meat
shield and and we're actually have had a
call-out we're doing some research to
see if someone can can I don't know
what's happened with the child I hope it
doesn't go into the system hope he gets
fostered or adopted by people who are
not abusive parents and teach them how
to be members of a productive society
and this would have gone unchecked once
it came out beyond all shadow of a doubt
that she was a child abuser it just
disappears so you have people who
believe the first story send them with
hands up don't shoot no it's very it's
very very hard to come back with the
truth when a story has been aired just
to the extent of Michael Brown got aired
right it's very very hard you know to to
counter with the truth of that stage I
mean it's extraordinary but what's
really amazing about the Ferguson play
which is obviously you know verbatim
from the testimony is the scenes at the
end and if you know if people if they
only watch one section of it watched you
know close to the end like five ten
minutes from the end where one witness a
black young woman is is giving is giving
evidence she says clearly and repeatedly
I don't like cops that's what she says
mm-hmm repeatedly and repeatedly I don't
like cops does everyone understand that
I just want you to know I wanted
recorded here I don't like cops she says
it over and over and over and over again
and then she says but here's what went
down her and then she describes what
happened and she said that cop was gonna
die they were when he was gonna kill
that cop and she says and she repeats
and repeats it I don't like cops so
here's a black woman from her own
community who doesn't like cops but who
told the truth and it's really powerful
and when it was done on stage I mean was
extraordinary people's reactions to
Orson Bean who you guys probably know
and father-in-law of and remark but but
also Emmy Award being director said it
was the best theater he'd seen in 20
years yeah and that's a that's a ringing
endorsement not the side note is there
anything whiter not Gager than a blonde
Irish lady saying that's how it went
down that's how I know you can play ball
that's why we do it with you here
otherwise you're gonna get triggered hey
have you been following this story of
the Leslie Jones nude photo leaks this
week no but I saw I saw
tweets from you this last few days since
you invited me on the show and I was
kind of going okay this nude photo thing
and I'm kind of doing about 12 things
the one time I think I was come back and
find out what it's no it's just Leslie
Jones the Ghostbusters black actress who
got my Twitter there were nude photos
leaked of her oh yes and yes Oh nude
photos leaked I'm not I'm not checking
the internet today see and they're like
oh oh that's so racist because I don't
want to look at leaked nude photos of
Leslie Jones I mean you were former
liberal right so yes you're okay now
but were you ever this against free
speech even when you were on the Left
were you ever all about the identity
politics and taking professional offense
because that's a new breed that I think
even you would have found foreign then
yeah no I think it's really weird I mean
I you know I'm trying to you know I I
just can't I I read stuff now and I
think almost everything I read I think
it's like an onion story because I'm
thinking there's no way that that's
there's no way they sent us there's no
way people said that you know you're
looking at stuff quotes from us from
salon and stuff like that you're
thinking no no where's nowhere they
defended pedophile three times though
they did three times I don't know if you
saw there's a great the great article in
The Wall Street Journal the other day
about this de sausage movie yeah the
sausage yeah I am Percy right and about
the older gender sex politics and
identity and all that sort of stuff and
I honestly there is an article in The
Wall Street Journal and I put it on my
Facebook page because I was kind of
going I was reading a salient stems to
me and I thought yeah I thought yeah you
know and actually you know it's true and
it's so extraordinary like
objecting like they're objecting yeah
you know to a part you know they're
they're objecting objecting burger
patties they're objecting to a comedy
but their objection and I said to fail
him I didn't even know what subcategory
this was because it's it's like it's
satire but it's even worse than that
because it's like setter on yourself and
of course this satire no normally goes
out towards society but this is a satire
on yeah I know I not to make the woman
joke but you can't get this he can't get
this broad to stop talking we'll talk
with her more after the break and
McIlhenny stay tuned
[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome back to Delilah Tracy I'm happy
to take your call none of us can what
can I help you with today are things
getting hot and heavy at home sometimes
those passionate relationships are the
flame that burns brightest there's
nothing like making a loving house oh no
an actual house fire it was electrical
there's nothing I like more than on an
autumn evening like tonight opening up a
book and curling up with a glass of wine
by the warm fire while I listen to the
tunes of Billy Joel do you like Billy
Joel no because I'd already dialed in
and you answered and I I need someone to
call the fire department
hmm I know how that feels how about the
Backstreet Boys I'm gonna die
[Music]
you
when a fire party
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back and McIlhenny Gosnell
movie.com sorry for that does just that
uncomfortable display and okay right
before we left you were saying about the
offended the Wall Street Journal yeah
the the offense at offense it's it is
hard and it happens both on the right on
the left now unfortunately where people
are so quick to try and take the moral
high ground by claiming offense
professional victimhood is a good
business and that's a perfect example
they were mad if I recall because the
fire water you know it's a bunch of
animated food and there was one that was
called a bottle of fire water and he was
a Native American and but there's also a
problem with the latina
who was a toxin the sausage should have
been some kind of yes so the latina is
what's up yeah is that is a taco but it
should have been better it was kind of
degrading that it was a tackle should
have been kind of a higher grade maybe
like I don't know let me find furniture
but then that's kind of offensive to
Germans so you know it they were writing
like this right we're writing like this
and they withdrew their had a previous
review for the person who reviewed the
film and then they review they withdrew
that and apologized they did he just
apologized
they wrote like 2,500 words of an
apology about all this latina taco
controversy doesn't if somebody's cherry
milling but if somebody said you know
like not that long ago you know our
forefathers you know fought and died you
know
fought and died for things that really
mattered and and and they exercised
their minds were exercised by how do we
NT be right no and and and things and
just things like that and now they're
protesting RuPaul for using the word
[ __ ] RuPaul talk about a Patton Oswalt
had a bit about that who's a liberal was
like RuPaul used the word trip it's like
this is the [ __ ]
and they're offended now I thought I
thought [ __ ] were allowed to call
themselves trolleys I thought they
pretty soon you won't be odd to say taco
techo however you say it as well okay so
speaking of miracles you've talked about
fracking a lot a lot a lot and people
know your story you worked your sort of
anti big energy and then you were
converted are I'm sure you have the
numbers the amount of jobs that have
been created under Barack Obama
the largest bulk of which is fracking I
was reading these reports that dude you
have the number what the percentages but
despite oh no I don't know I don't have
a number I don't have a number but it's
extraordinary I think even the numbers
that are even the numbers that are given
are unrepresentative because what you
want you what they don't count is people
in you know in in balloon making shops
are in party shops are in hairdressing
salons or nail salons who have got jobs
only because fracking has come to town
and their business is reopened that was
shuttered so I think they do the
transformation and it's funny it's a
very interesting thing that you bring up
fracking right now because I just think
in all the noise at the selection and
well you know that's not something we're
going to talk about maybe not today
Stephen sure but in all the noise of
this election I wish people would talk
about the issues because here's what I
know in this election it's super clear
that this is actually an antler and
election about fracking
yeah because one candidate is going to
close it down completely and one
candidate isn't so I think that should
be something that people should put
first when they start talking about
candidate suitability there's another
candidate by the way and we may get on
to talking about ghazal there's one
candidate who thinks it's great good and
something important that in America you
can kill a baby in the womb up until
nine months now one candidate believes
that strenuously courageously believes
that and will fight for that will fight
to the end for this and one candidate
doesn't right I wish people would talk a
little bit more about that because I
actually think to me actually that
really matters the last sure I think
there's a lot of people that would
matter a lot that it matters a lot to me
nine months you know yes and I just
think we should maybe talk a little bit
more about that and I'm disappointed by
conservatives getting distracted
I understand servitors who who pivoted
when Donald Trump did was very
disappointing on an answer and abortion
and he actually cancelled a show with
one of my friends because this person
said you know what I was disappointed by
his answer on this and everyone got
furious so I think you're I think now
it's come to light but I also think
because it's so important we need to
hold their feet to the fire Democrat or
Republican and there's been a lot of
missteps on the right with that as well
yeah yeah but I just think I just think
it's an interesting one I don't you know
you're just talking about fracking yes
abortion the answer on abortion but I I
agree with you listen I've always said
this I'm I'm a Christian I don't go out
and I don't preach in the show right I
think you have a funny show you have a
show people want to watch and you try
and be the best example you can now it
doesn't mean that I'm a single-issue
voter however the life issue is a closed
tainted issue I can't vote for someone
who is okay abortion up until birth like
a Bernie like a Hillary and I'm amazed
that we've talked about this not kids
earn a lot of even homeschooled young
Christian kids who said well Bernie is
about social justice but he was even
worse and said up until the day of birth
I believe it's the woman's right to
choose and I don't know how anyone who
respects life could could be on board
with that yeah you know I can't I can't
really add anything to that
to me it's good I just find it
extraordinary I'm amazed but of course
it kind of it reinforces this idea of
thought of how incredibly in the tank
the media are for Hillary Clinton cuz to
me it seems like a killer question to me
it's a really killer question are you
saying you know one of my colleagues
here Magda I love that she has a great
phrase a great way of thinking she says
basically isn't it incredible that this
is something that you would get out on
you know it would take an awful lot
Steven for me to get out with a placard
on the street just that's me right right
I find the whole tidy of protesting
tough but that you would be someone
who'd protest for the right to kill a
baby at nine months it's kind of amazing
right so I think to ask someone that who
wants to be pressed in the United States
I think it's a really good question I
think it's a question that people would
find very very interesting to hear the
answer to that and I just wish somebody
did ask her that and I wish we'd heard
we hear more about this and I worry
actually that there'll be debates and
that won't be asked because they won't
ask
I think yeah I think a big part of it
too is you know we've talked about this
we just we've had John Nolte on today
and Curt Schilling who are a big Trump
people we had Ben Shapiro on is not very
Pro Trump I think it's a question that's
important it's imperative to the
character of our nation and it does
disappoint I think a lot you see what's
this sort of populist trumpism gonna
said well we need to abandon that
completely I understand pro-life isn't
necessarily a winning issue that you run
on but it's an important issue yes yes
and I think it's by the way I think all
of these things go to
the beliefs of the countess and I think
the beliefs of the cabinet are very
important I think people have me to have
them laid out very clearly and obviously
there's nuance here and there or
whatever but things like that I think
are great I think for the lack of a
candidate I don't think he'll unlike
Barack Obama
I don't think Hillary Clinton actually
believes anything I think he was an
ideologue I think she what's the poll
today and then she consults with with
with with Beelzebub and we get our
answer and McIlhenny we have to go
Gosnell movie.com speaking of that where
else can people find you they can find
mcenany on facebook and ghazal will be
calm as I said today and we still are
collect we have to go and you talk so
much we need you again for another
segment next week and McIlhenny we will
plug her again
this election season America Harper
wants your vote but how much do you
really know about Harper are you aware
that he's a dog Oh Argentino as in from
Argentina he's not even American is it
too much to ask for Harper's birth
certificate
why don't know all the dogs from puppy
daycare even remember him what's he
hiding in his pants and his running mate
Dean Cain he claims he's only part
Japanese but he looks really agen to me
should Superman be Asian in Argentinian
and in Asian running for president and
vice president of America unfit
unqualified and unamerican
this month in her new comedy special amy
schumer's offended by everything such um
I don't care I'll take the yoga mat and
the sandwich then I took Jenny Craig out
back and had her kidnapped just call me
fat you think it's funny to have a
weight problem
so you think struggling with a thyroid
disorder is funny kind of you're an all
right
everyone tell him
stay tuned for more comedy on the
cutting edge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back third hour coming up
after the break we will have John Nolte
who people love have been asking have
been requesting John Nolte I'm your host
even credit producing at the end video
studio as always is not gauge here and
follow him on Twitter at not K Jared I
fulfilled my legal obligations draw your
own conclusions gosh I hope we have an
McIlhenny back on when we talk about the
whole Gosnell deal good and hopefully
Jeff nation was fantastic right nation
was a fail haven't seen that one it was
a high-quality film and in rebuttal to
is it Josh Fox Josh Fox is guest land
which is just awful I was just talking
about a about that film at a an old
naked man in the hot tub at the gym
today that's normal tell him how much he
loved Michael Moore and I I'm surprised
I'm surprised because you told meadow
you met him you met him the one Michael
Moore fan Michael Moore fit but he was
shocked when I told about Roger and me
and how Michael Moore actually got the
interview with thorium and claims that
he didn't and then he's like really huh
well you know I never been fact-checked
on that but that's it I'll need to go
and he just completely changed his mind
and then he was talking about his
shotgun
I said well Michael Moore doesn't you
know doesn't even really believe in the
private private citizenry's right to
bear to own any firearms he said what
listen yeah have you seen Bowling for
Columbine no he had only seen the last
two his mind was changed so these little
date that's why I say to people the
little day-to-day interactions you will
be stunned as to how quickly people are
willing to change their mind speaking
we'll get into a little inside baseball
with John Nolte I know people have been
asking he left Breitbart he's working
sometimes working with daily wire ben
shapiro
he's super Pro Trump I think that's an
interesting dynamic we'll talk with him
about that we'll get to in a couple of
minutes this week in outrage for those
on Twitter this week and social justice
warrior outrage something I thought was
interesting I touched on earlier new
report says transgenderism has no
scientific basis so we wrote about it at
ladder with credit calm but let me just
give you the briefing in the study
Arizona State University professor of
statistics and biostatistics Lawrence s
mayor and John Hopkins University
Medical School professor of psychiatrics
Paul McHugh co-authored a report which
examined top peer-reviewed studies and
the biological psychological
Sciences this is the quote examining
research from the biological
psychological and social sciences this
report shows that some of the most
frequently heard claims about sexuality
and gender are not supported by
scientific evidence remember this one
leftist claim that your anti science
among the key findings listed by the
authors was that the hypothesis that
gender identity is an innate fixed
property of human beings that is
independent of biological sex meaning
there is somehow a difference between
gender and sex that's all thing the term
now gender is not sex that's what they
teach on campus that a person might be
trapped in a woman's body or a woman
trapped in a man's body is not supported
by any scientific evidence children are
a special case when addressing
transgender issues only a minority of
children who experience cross gender
identifications will continue to do so
into adolescence or adulthood the
authors continued so you can read the
wrote about a ladder with Crider calm it
came to us from I think we found I don't
know where we found that Daily Caller
this is important to note because the
left will always tell you that you are
the party or the anti science party
we're going to do a big video on the
climate change
you're a climate change denier member
Bill Maher said Bill Maher Bill Nye
Milan you're a climate change denier
you're a science denial well what do
people really mean when they say that
you're a climate science deniers they
mean you disagree with my proposed
legislation based on hypothetical
climate science here's something that is
medically observable scientifically
observable you don't really need to hope
to one day test a hypothesis ten years
down the line forty years down the line
maybe when Florida is gone as al gore
predicted you can look at the evidence
we have available you can do a meta
study which they've done you can you can
track whatever rands Mitter activity
what's happening in certain portions of
the brain whether it's the you know the
frontal was it cerebral cortex we had
dr. Boniface on talking about the
portion that creates this this idea of
self-awareness your perception of
yourself you can observe these things
that's science and the science on this
is is becoming more and more definitive
that despite what they teach on college
campuses despite what they mandate over
there at ESPN you say there is no gender
doesn't there's biological sex there are
extreme case
whether it's hermaphrodites we all look
not let's not go to the outliers which
left us try to do to prove their
mainstream science so it's interesting
this is a very definitive study and I
would love to have some of the the
transgender guests out there who are
more sort of alt-right conservative
who've been upset and we've talked about
this before it doesn't mean that I
dislike anyone who's transgender it
doesn't mean that I hate them I wish
them the best I just don't think the
best thing is to inject hormones into
their balls hey wait
does that sound outrageous that brings
us to our next segment this week is
social justice warrior outrage so this
week in social justice warrior outrage
we have a few stories to get to we're
doing so many of these stories or said
you know we have to condense this down
to a segment yeah Matt's promised as
promised let's recap the first one we
talked about it in the first hour of
course the dildos there at UT people are
so outraged that Americans are
exercising their second Amendment rights
that they decided to wave around dildos
because one does bring that back up to
something that you should note if you
look at these tweets all these stories
it's illegal in Texas to carry to
display sex toys but not guns UT
students are staging unique protests of
campus carry two likes one retain the
interactions that come from these
leftist these I'm always wondering if
they've bought these accounts again this
person nobody really cares about the
people throwing dildos around in Texas
they're outraged because they're
professionally outraged if it wasn't
someone carrying guns it would be the
fact that somebody was born a white male
let's go on to the next story where
people were outraged Oh Hope Solo has
been suspended six months this happened
this week soccer player I believe
because she said that the Swedes were
cowards
she said the Swedes were playing to win
like a point game they weren't really
leaving it all out there in the field
she said they are cowards and she has
been suspended condemned for trash talk
condemned for trash talk do you realize
Don Cherry Hockey Night in Canada he
used to say that all the time those damn
Swedes they always hit you cross-check
your from behind Karen the other guy no
sport would exist NFL would not exist
every player would be the end right all
right there's a certain level sure I'm
sure tasteful but to ban someone for
saying it by the way so we
cowards I'm not even gonna lie to you
Swedes and if it's not if you're not
cowards if you're Swedish you're just
perceived that way you're perceived as
cowards when we think of Swedes we think
of people who have contributed very
little to modern society except for I
think birth control and beds that fold
into desk chairs to the sweetest fish of
hindustan I don't even know if those are
Swedish probably not the horse meat the
[ __ ] chef the Muppet chef but you know
you're not bringing a whole lot to the
table Sweden and so we have to peg you
with something it just so happens based
on prior behavior um cowardice is a good
fit on you we have another store we have
two more one more two more two more oh
okay oh this was a big one this week
trending all over the place was black
womens
equal payday so of course Bernie Sanders
Chuck Schumer Amy Schumer's little ah
hunky tuck there representative barbara
Lee they were talking about how the
gender wage gap isn't about women's
choices it's about how we value their
work and all of these black women on
Twitter were we're outraged and I don't
know I'm making only 60% of what white
men make and this was trending here's
the crazy thing of course it's
completely untrue but we know this of
course it's completely untrue it's not
because you're black it's not because of
the melanin in your skin is because of
level of education it's because of the
field that you chose to go into someone
who gets a bachelor's and chooses to go
into Social Work is not going to do as
well as somebody who chooses to go into
a very advanced science field that
requires years upon years of schooling
and then has a specialized job position
available really easy gender pay gap
myth google it you can find information
within we've done videos on it we've
done videos on it many times it is
completely false it is there and I will
give it no ground none I even have some
friends or relatives who are relative
conservative like well that's sure I say
no no it's not true at all it's one of
those things you don't need to give them
any leeway it's completely false here's
the scary part Bernie Sanders Hillary
Clinton your representatives are
tweeting this out so you have a decision
to make is Bernie Sanders an absolute
[ __ ] I don't think he is or is he
dishonest is Barack Obama an absolute
simpleton or is he lying is Hillary
and functionally [ __ ] of course
she's functionally what I had to do it
because people are asking ya to do
impression by the way pcs beard shoutout
one of our biggest fans apparently he
needed a shout-out I haven't seen him in
a while I've seen him on Twitter a
little bit here and there hopefully he's
doing well pcs beard yeah are these
people idiots it's not the fact that a
bunch of dumb Twitter mobsters and
hashtag warriors are are carrying
misinformation out into the blogosphere
it's that the elite the representatives
who know better are spreading the
submiss information so you have to
decide are they stupid or are they liars
and that's really important because I
don't say that about every single issue
I don't say that someone believes in
climate change they're an idiot I think
that you could probably look at some
science on both sides of that and I
think that there are people who make
compelling arguments on both sides there
is no compelling argument to
substantiate the wage gap myth none
anymore and Hillary Clinton is smart
enough to know that but she's going to
go out and pair this anyway that that's
the concerning part not not not the Shan
Kings of it by the way when I saw Shaun
White was trending I always thought I
was a play off someone's taken someone's
taken the leak out of Shaun King but no
he was actually shown what we have one
last one last one yep one last story Oh
Leslie Jones the the the the big black
lady from ghostbusters
so okay nudes of her leaked she was
hacked which is horrible by the way just
four people maybe of Hillary Clinton's
listening iCloud is not a secured server
I just want people to know that now
don't store your nudes on iCloud
now is this a horrible violation of
privacy yeah do I think it's terrible if
they did this to this that this person
absolutely I tweeted out Oh nude
pictures of Leslie Jones are on the
internet today nope that's what I
tweeted him but I was leaving the
Internet I didn't want to see them right
away the tweets came in racist how dare
you say that and I was accosted
digitally for not wanting to see a woman
naked it's not enough for you to say wow
this is terrible that someone was hacked
but man I don't want to see those naked
pictures it's not enough free too
say okay I get it I defend her right to
privacy but I don't you have to care you
must agree with other people's
definitions of beauty this is what
happens in social justice left this is
why they're constantly outraged it's
good business to be outraged you make
more money if you're a professional
victim now why work hard to get it just
just clean victim status and there's a
grant or a scholarship somewhere John
Nolte coming up next
[Music]
you
this week in not racist oh my god did
you sure about Leslie Jones no her phone
got hacked and there are nude pictures
of her all over the internet Oh God oh
no remind me not to go on the internet
today why would you say that what it's
clear well I would say that it's
unbelievably offensive what how was that
offensive you don't want to see her nude
pictures just because she's black what
no that no I don't want to see them
because she's heinous ly unattractive
because she's black no I've seen plenty
of naked black women and liked it I
watched monsters ball
oh really okay so you're not racist no
no she's just ugly okay well then how
about you prove it all right fine show
me the naked Leslie Jones picture wow I
can't believe that you were willing to
perpetuate rape culture so quickly okay
how do I get out of this one unscathed
what do you want to pin this on today is
it racism or sexism well today we're
definitely focusing more on sexism okay
put me down for because she's black good
choice this has been this week in non
racist
[Music]
we're glad to be back confused our next
guest you can find him on Twitter at No
Fee NC writes for The Daily wire comm
was also my first ever ever editor when
I was writing at at well bright part it
was big Hollywood bright part.com man
John Nolte thanks for being here sir my
pleasure
no God glad to have you on so I mean how
long ago was that I was 20 and John was
it was it was big Hollywood bright
part.com because was Android and get the
rights to big Hollywood or something and
I remember I heard Andrew Breitbart on
the Dennis Miller show and I thought wow
this seems like an interesting guy it's
a place for conservatives to write he
was really passionate about it and I
just reached out to him when he talked
for 45 minutes on the phone with me ran
a stand-up clip said it did well he's
like hey do you ever want to think about
writing and then he put me in touch with
you and you you were the one who taught
me the ropes yeah we launched the day
after Barack Obama took the oath of
office but the day before he violated it
so it was right now because eight years
ago so a lot of people now maybe right
bar don't even know the sort of big
Hollywood story you were brought in
because you did was it dirty Harry's
place you had a blog that was pretty
popular yeah that was one of the few
people I had worked in a very little for
a few years and I was writing a blog
called Dirty Harry's place and I was one
of the few people that looked at
Hollywood and looked at film and pop
culture from a conservative point of
view but I didn't look at it from sort
of what you might call a moralistic
point of view right do you have a and
there's a place for that don't don't
misunderstand me I'm not knocking
anymore but I don't really care for
movies r-rated or kind of new to these
or anything like that and I'm actually I
kind of like nudity if it's tasteful
yeah but but and female as long as she's
a good shape well that's so I guess that
negates girls on HBO
yeah and goes
Buster's but but so I was looking at it
from fear purely a film lovers point of
view and Andrew liked that he thought
that it would be good to have a right of
center you know from from conservative
people who are conservative Christian
straight through the libertarian and
when it comes to movies I'm more
libertarian and that's that's just how
it ended up happening so I was his first
editor-in-chief I remember that and it
was it was a crazy time I remember there
were a couple
I remember the what do you remember the
one video that we didn't run at
Breitbart that I did the first one that
Andrew said we can't do this it was too
controversial back then do you know what
it was no it was it was the one where I
did the the illegal immigration one and
I said let's set up a Wailing Wall
because it'll confuse the Mexicans and
he was just never any yes yes I was I
was going to I was leading up to that
yeah you were like it's funny we just we
can't do this right now fast forward now
and and I don't I don't think we'd have
that much of a problem with it I think
the political correctness thing is kind
of swung the other way and obviously
with with the website now with his with
his name on the header and I don't think
there'd be an issue you know at the time
I was just doing you know and those
basically were my decisions he intercept
down and we talked well the whole four
years I worked for him I was an editor
about what his guidelines were so it's
really up to me to to interpret them and
that he said in a number of cases I
always interpreted on the you know to be
as cautious as possible yes you know you
wanted to be able to defend it and avoid
an unnecessary controversy and it wasn't
that your video wasn't funny cuz it was
no but I remember yeah back in that
especially that's I'm Andrew Breitbart
was a manager Brett recorded a lot of
people he ran in circles where he had to
make sure that he even though he wasn't
afraid of speaking out he didn't want to
needlessly offend people for the sake of
offending people I always remember that
about him or he was saying if your right
to it yeah if you're right you're right
that's funny always said do your due
diligence remember he called me with
that video and he said do your due
diligence you're young you know
compliments whatever he gave me and then
he said but
right now is not the time to storm the
castle trust me I'll tell you when it is
never thinking you know what all right
and he was one of the few people we said
trust me and it wasn't just a buzz
phrase I said okay I will yeah yeah you
know the guy had a master plan in his
head and you know I think it was Andrew
Clavin who said this don't take credit
for it but the reason that Andrew
Breitbart could talk so much and talk to
everyone and he was one of the few
people who could do that and not get
into trouble is because he always told
the truth right and so he could talk to
a thousand people and there was never a
situation where he told me no sir he
told me that or he said this to me about
you or you said that because he just
wasn't that way he always told the truth
and when you always tell the truth you
don't have to worry about how many
people you talk to or what you talk
about to give you an idea how much he
told the truth Andrew if I didn't know
him better almost almost almost creepily
was fond of my wife really like my wife
was the first to RSVP enter at our
wedding
you primer when he went out to Western
Michigan he loved it I remember we were
talking about he just loved that his
kids were out there and he said they
were off their phones and I remember we
were at UH gosh was a capita was in DC
it was Andrew it was mrs. Coulter and a
few other people who we would know
behind the scenes and my wife and I had
I think just gotten engaged and we were
walking out we were there for CPAC as
we're walking out because I have to get
up and host the next morning I've told
the story on this show before but you
may not know it he we hear someone kind
of laughing giggling behind us and it's
my wife and he goes your problem in case
you hadn't noticed is that you're not
tall or hot enough his way of
complimenting right there my wife just
melted said we know what a sweet guy and
and he would talk with her like they
were old friends when they met so let me
ask you this because I do think you're a
big Pro Trump guy you write a daily wire
now you don't write it bright but I
don't think it's any secret and and Ben
is obviously kind of a never Trump guy
but I do think you embody a lot of what
what Andrew was about in the sense that
you've never targeted people for
disagreeing with you you haven't gotten
into the back-and-forth of Trump or Die
was that a conscious decision do you
think it's Andrew that rubbed off
you were it's it's a noticeable change
from a lot of people online right now
well I don't I mean I had the same on my
I don't know what you follow my Twitter
feed but my saying online is I never
started I was just sitting here eating
an ice cream cone and that's what I will
I'm online I'm very tough on the media
because I hate the media but I don't go
after people on our own side I don't
pluck them out of nowhere and just
attack them personally but if they come
after me I go after them but no I don't
like to go after people personally one
of the things I like about ben shapiro
is that as much as we disagree on this
issue
hold that thought i forgot if there are
corporate overlords John Nolte at Nolte
NC oh I'm hanging on his every word now
I want to know where this goes don't you
and stay tuned or you'll never know
[Music]
this week in not racist it has been
brought to my attention that not wanting
to look at the recently leaked nude
photos of Leslie Jones is perceived as
racist in my defense
here's a list of other females I don't
want to see naked Amy Schumer Lena
Dunham Katie Couric cher Sinead O'Connor
the cast of The Golden Girls Melissa
McCarthy the made from The Brady Bunch
Kristen Wiig all other female comedians
Tess Holliday the sea witch
Ursula Elizabeth Warren but not because
she's one eighteenth Cherokee Hillary
Clinton cher Rachel Maddow Oprah Winfrey
damn it this has been this week and not
racist
[Music]
glad to be back at Nolte NC John Nolte
was talking about Ben Shapiro
he writes over there I guess sort of on
a part-time basis that daily wire.com
John sorry we had to cut you off the
floor is yours
oh well what I like about Ben Ben I've
been friends a long time about 10 years
now sure he's not as bad as all the
nevertrump people where he's completely
just trying to destroy the guy and I'm
Pro Trump and him and I would you know
we've never had a problem personally we
debated we disagree and when I left I
resigned from Breitbart in March and I
was going to start my own site because I
still want to have a voice out there I
sort of want to have something to say
but I can't take a job in that business
until after my my non-compete is up so I
found that one out the hard way as a
youngin but yes yeah yes so bad asked me
he's like well if you want to write
something because I had a piece of off
Muhammad Ali I wanted to publish when he
died he said we'll put it up here and
then he said listen you can write
anything you want for us and if you want
to criticize nevertrump you could
criticize never Trump I thought my gosh
I mean how open-minded is that because
he's allowing me to go on his site and
do that and the great thing about what I
love about it is that I didn't have to
launch my own site which would have been
a lot more work so I'm just popping off
a couple three pieces a week and I'm
enjoying the rest of my summer do you
feel that a being in the Trump camp and
obviously it's no secret well listen
it's no secret that Breitbart is a pro
Trump site because the guy the guy you
handed it up is now running at the Trump
campaign so it's not an accusation this
is just observing it yeah you've been in
both camps this is clearly in the tank
for Trump at Breitbart and daily wire is
clearly has an anti Trump angle to it do
you feel that you're more free on the
other side even though you're Pro Trump
do you feel like there's a difference in
open-mindedness or is it kind of the
same on the other side of the coin I
never ever I there is no primary
candidate I criticized more at Breitbart
during the primary process than Donald
Trump
I probably wrote people can look it up I
mean I probably wrote eight to ten piece
is critical to Trump on Breitbart
mm-hmm and everybody's
to make this into a sinister thing this
leak about how we had to put all those
pieces through through the top floor
through the sewers there Bannon and Alex
Marlowe and Larry solo but of course we
had to that's the way these things work
and so I pitched every negative piece
and every positive piece that I wrote
about Trump and I never was told no not
once was I told no and that includes
Fannin in some cases I I was told I was
always encouraged so in my experience I
never I never had and I've never had a
problem the daily wire they've they've
published everything I've said to them
they don't even change the headlines so
they've just been wonderful
has it been at all and again like you
said if I know with contract issues has
it been at all uncomfortable since
obviously they've they've really
attacked ben shapiro a lot of Breitbart
since he's left that's no secret
and Ben is fired back recently when
Bannen is taking this role with the
Trump campaign have this is it at all
like mom and dad are fighting for you or
you just keep keep your nose down and do
the work because you know that happens
all the time it happens everywhere and I
just as long I'm just not a part of it
and it's not just happening a Breitbart
I mean there's so much there's so much
inside warfare right now it's hard to
believe so I I just I just don't think
about it but it's not something that I
would ever want to engage I'd rather
stick to the ideas than get into a feud
with except on Twitter I love use that
to it yes it's true but I never started
I never stopped that's true because nor
the one time there was a fake account a
John Nolte account and they was going
like why would you why would you said
you really know that wasn't me and that
was it because I remember being really
kind of disappointed I understood that
you know with the inside with Breitbart
where I had written there and and
there's obviously some politics but I
was like John I would never do myself
following that count for a while I'm
like I was like cuz it looked so much
like Haman was the same insane innocent
they are followers yeah it was cleared
up right away see isn't that wonderful
was cleared up by me just going John I
do this is kind of a dick move and you
just said it's true well not get your
eliminate the pictures that we have that
we Photoshop have deleted
well I'm glad to hear that I think one
thing to a lot of people owners
and first let me ask this do you think
this these wounds heal after Hilary most
likely wins let's say Donald Trump maybe
wins the numbers aren't looking good do
you think these cracks healed for
example do you think the people at
Breitbart will say okay Ben let's let's
come together now we have to do you
think people do you think the cracks can
ever can never be filled in and mended
no well I think they can eventually but
I think that even if Trump loses I don't
think that the movement is going to end
and then the movement is huge it's the
biggest thing in politics and really in
probably since the Reagan Revolution
period the Trump movement the populist
the populist I'm taking over taking over
there right nationalism taking over the
right I think it's a very real movement
Trump didn't start and he just captured
it and and I think that never Trump the
people and I might talk about guys like
Ben who can be reasonable even though I
think he's wrong I'm talking about like
the National Review and Jonah Goldberg
and Stuart Stevens and these guys that
are constantly Amanda carpenter
constantly on Twitter trying to
undermine him sabotage him they're
constantly on cable news buying into
every mainstream media narrative even
intellectually dishonest ones and I
think if they don't do if no one's
asking them to lie no one's asking them
to violate their conscience but should
they be a conscientious objector and
just stay quiet and not violate your
conscience or you could be a saboteur
for Hillary thinks valid criticisms
doesn't make someone a saboteur
constructive it's good and I've
criticized exactly because you've done
that there's nothing wrong with well I
guess for example right now this week I
would be lying if I would say that it
doesn't concern me that he softened his
rhetoric on the illegal immigration
which is one of the things I really
liked about him where he's kind of said
well I'm gonna do what George Bush and
Obama did well hold on because the big
selling point for you is weren't going
to do that and and I think that's fair
to say that's not what we were so that's
this total that's good I'm about I just
submitted a piece of the daily water
talking about how much trouble I think
he's in and that is constructive
analysis but when you start calling him
a racist and you start calling him
stupid
I just see there's this narrative that
the
started to get Barack Obama elected and
reelected and they've done it again
where the Republican can do absolutely
nothing right no matter what McCain or
Romney or Trump does it's wrong
everything else but wrong and when I see
never Trump jumping on that bandwagon
where nothing it it's so intellectually
dishonest right that is sabotage and
that to me is not going to be forgiven
I'm not gonna forgive it these are the
same jerks that demanded that I soldier
up for Romney who was who isn't any more
conservative than Trump and McCain who
was completely feckless remember I'm
going to suspend my campaign I'm gonna
jump on my white horse but I have
nowhere I have no idea where I'm gonna
go right and they're both more fascist
than Trump mccain-feingold and Rob
Romneycare you kidding me so the idea
that I'm told to soldier up and that
they stab us in the back I'm not gonna
forget right but I think there's also
because I've been told to sort by people
you and I would both know to soldier up
for Trump or will be eliminated and
purged and as you know I'm not even in
the never Trump campaign we've written
many articles praising him I've said
he's not a racist I don't think he's a
sexist I think he's pretty disrespectful
sometimes of women I think the way he
speaks in a way would turn off female
voters which statistically is observable
I'm going strategically it's not smart
to say what he said but I don't think
he's sexist I don't think any of those
things are true but yeah I I understand
where you're coming from and the
soldiering up do this is a problem and
it is a problem with these these these
intellectually dishonest people on the
right who do that however it is also
intellectually dishonest when you have
people in the Trump side I think we
would both agree who paint yes Carly
Fiorina and Ted Cruz as establishment I
think it's important to define what that
is because I agree I mean no one was a
bigger fan of Ted Cruz and Andrew
Breitbart no one that I can tell you
there's a big difference you know are
plenty of horrible pro Trump people out
there and as someone who supported Marco
Rubio has supported Ted Cruz throughout
most of the primary I can tell you that
because I got I got as many tweets from
them as anyone else did as many nasty
email or even got phone calls because
I'm dumb enough to be listed but but the
phone call from angry Rubio people can't
yet do it from my angry trumpet okay so
just a couple of because
but but the nasty Trump people primarily
are just people on the Internet it stir
the nasty never Trump people are the
people that are named people that are
that make it on television they're part
of the establishment these are people
that are respected and that to me is all
I don't know I would say that's true
considering you know Fox News I think
now people who said listen they're
clearly in the tank for Trump
the brass have been vindicated not all
personalities after this about Fox News
like you I was never told you have to
say this but I was always made aware
that the brass thought a certain way and
if you wanted to be in in good with them
it would serve you well to think that
way I think with Roger Ailes I think
we've seen that there are some pretty
high up executives who would be the same
in the pro Trump side but whatever is
just a nastiness online the nastiness
and the nastiness the nastiness that I
face from the pro Trump people were the
eggs on online but maybe that's what
they were the nastiness that I get from
the for the never Trump people are names
we all recognize and these are people
within the establishment these are
people that are part of the consultant
class and they're just as vicious and
nasty as the nobodies on Twitter the
love of Trump to me that's a big
distinction well I think something you
do differently and the reason we wanted
to have you on the program is you're
still actually making the case for Trump
for some people like I said because you
understand there are people who could be
conscientious objectors who may not be
able to pull that lever
we had Gavin McInnes on and I love him
but I don't think there are a lot of pro
Trump people making the case anymore and
they say well we don't have to because
if you don't vote for him it's a vote
for Hillary well that's not enough
because there are people who need to
hear in case made sure my dad is now my
dad was a huge Pro Trump guy and now
he's now he's saying I don't think I can
go so I do a change for him just to land
the three weeks after the convention he
just was this is actually what I wrote
about for The Daily wire the piece is
going to go up there is my dad is the
ultimate truck for every 77 very very
but my final you know energetic he's not
old
he's working-class he was chased out of
Milwaukee by the spreading crime he's he
loved Trump during the primary and then
those sort of three weeks after his
convention were trouble just when just
got into one stupid contra her
after another now my dad say and I you
know I can't vote for the guy and that's
when we're gonna be more than anything
and I hate but you're right though we
have to reach those people Trump has to
get back to where he's tied with Hillary
and if he can just bring back the
Republicans which is what I think he's
trying to do now he can at least get
tied with Hillary again but you know
what to see if he can do it okay
changing gears real quick Jared who does
who doesn't Nolte look like I've always
said this Daniel Stern exactly oh you
know I told you that years ago right
just thought about as soon as he popped
on like I'd say hard I swear you I've
never
John I've never talked with Nadia Jared
about that at all that's totally
unplumbed but he's coming back out now
you did a video of him with a tarantula
do you see that Daniel Stern yes I can
see his profile picture looks like um I
think the guy his family that is who it
is his
yes but that was before Modern Family's
his favorite show okay yeah that's very
married with children which by the way
completely disagree with Jonah I hate
married with children I love that O'Neal
I hate mine good job oh yeah I don't
know I see I think of him back to little
giants you know what else people don't
realize probably the toughest guy in
Hollywood probably it's a black belt in
black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu directly
under the Gracie's did he play for the
Steelers
he played Popeye Doyle and a TV version
of the French Connection I mean he's a
tough guy
oh that's right I forgot about it yeah I
know he has hands that are like just you
know like Polish sausages on meat hooks
people don't realize how big he is and
he was an athlete either Division one I
think he played or was adventure in the
NFL and now as a black belt moves on you
did sue so but Daniel Stern Ed O'Neill
is in the picture get it right John we
have to go but where is the best place
for people to find you well they can
find me on Twitter at Nolte and olt ENC
where they can find me I'm ready right
now for the daily water for daily wire
kamo if you follow them on the Twitter
whether you're Pro Trump or not Trump
just don't start it because it's like
make sure you're following the right one
yeah it's like a it's like a prairie dog
if you start it with them it just
gets ugly and then someone has to be put
down
no mr. no-fee thank you very much we
must go sonic sonic
outros and that means were speeding up
speeding up - the what - the last
segment
[Music]
welcome back to Delilah on this lovely
August evening
Travis I'm so happy to be taking your
call I'm glad to be on the air my
girlfriend don't listen to me hmm
sometimes we all have those moments in
our lives where we feel on her she just
Tunes me out and doesn't listen to what
I have to say at all well the important
thing is to remember that whatever it is
she's going through I have no doubt she
loves you and you'll get through it
together not sure about that
what kind of examples would you have of
her maybe not listening to you as you'd
like I like particularly when I put her
in the closet for days on end I know
that feeling sometimes all of us feel
when the world gets to be a little too
much that we want to excuse ourselves to
a closet no I literally put her in a
club in a broom Club
I'm sorry what yeah I put her in a broom
closet I slide under the door
food pin sandwiches mm-hmm I know that
feeling
sometimes I feel trapped in a closet
with my anxiety in the world's too much
I just need my husband to slide my
figurative bread of life under the broom
closet door no I mean I literally mash
down a sandwich and like with a mallet
and I just slide it under the door but
she hasn't I mean maybe she's not so
much not listening to me she might be
dead well sometimes all of us just need
to feel dead to the world
what other nice things do you do for
your girlfriend do you give her anything
else under the door well Travis sounds
like you care about her a lot so do me a
favor and put your phone up to the door
while I play the perfect song just for
you and Emily from James Taylor
okay Emily you doing there yes yesterday
morning they let me know you
[Music]
that was a close one glad to be that I'm
exhausted
whoo last second of the show thanks so
much to all our guests John Nolte for
coming on right away gosh we get you
know we had Ben Shapiro on Gavin on that
same week with right scoop is super
Mexican on last week is Annie Trump this
week we had Curt Schilling on who's Pro
everybody where John and people are mad
that we have John Nolte on I just can't
keep track of this anymore conservatives
Republicans I just can't keep track of
who I'm not supposed to have on anymore
because you're mad this week apparently
I'm in the tank for Trump but I'm also
apparently a cuck shill for the
establishment obviously well their
checks clear well yeah never had it
never had a check bounced from the
establishment let's just sell it all and
start doing reviews on pointless tech
crap or something
yeah reviews on films many gun films
guns review gun reviews at Alana's
Crowder you can tweet us
Chuy's lover Chewbacca's lover one of
our best fans out there did say and he
had a valid criticism about what John
Nolte said he said Eric Bolling Sean
Hannity Ann Coulter or not Twitter eggs
they are big profiles who have called
out and attacked Trump critics I think
that's fair I just like I think it's
fair to tell Jared to stop clicking his
damn pen no more just no more Jared it
is finished back to you
I think that's valid listen with the
Sean Hannity think people were asking me
more more questions about about Fox News
with andrea tantaros coming out if
there's a lot of people who said well
you've alluded it and you haven't talked
about it no one wants to hear you talk
about your former employer and I don't
think that whatever I would say people
would necessarily believe one way or the
other it's like someone someone leaves
McDonald's and says toothpaste whatever
it is but you know what I'm talking
about
I do have some stories though and I will
say this there are some things that
you're hearing in the news that are true
and some that I would give me pause I
don't know are true but I'll leave it
maybe I'll talk my feet enough people
email me or tweet me by the way I got so
many horrible airline stories from last
week oh really awful air talks about our
horrible story we talked about our story
and
got so many stories one guy he said
death is it Les Paul as a guitar Les
Paul yeah he was traveling and guess
with ministry and they they handled his
luggage so poorly they broke the neck to
his Les Paul and they refused to fix
because I said that the luggage itself
didn't have damage so they never did
anything to fix it I think I heard that
story before the story I don't know
someone sent it to me in an email so we
were talking about this earlier about
professional victimhood is the the
fastest-growing business in the United
States and I had some people say what do
you mean can you expand on that well I
wrote about it on the website and this
is true and this is very important
because I do see a lot of young people
going all right what's the what's the
fastest path to victory it's normal for
humans to try and pick the path of least
resistance and right now if you are
going to look at your options you're
going to weigh them as a young American
and say okay what's my best shot at
success here there are many instances
not all but many instances in which your
passive path of least resistance would
be to simply play the victim card in
lieu of working hard in lieu of doing a
good job look at an example in Courtenay
I wrote about this Courtney and I wrote
about this I didn't have a stroke for
some reason we get later in the show
it's late I'm tired feminists let's get
into feminists they depend on perpetual
victim status lest they join another
victim group to welfare recipients so
that depend on the victim status they
need that to stay gainfully employed so
they keep the gender pay gap myth alive
we were talking about that right it's
verifiably we know it's not true but
they celebrate it they constantly trot
it out there that's their that's their
ace in the hole is the gender pay gap
myth and when you say well it's really
not true what do they do they get
furious at you you you are you're
basically a science denier you're you're
uh you're a woman denier how could you
say that of course the listen if you
were a woman and you wanted to be paid
the same as a man and someone said hey
listen I'm a woman I'm a feminist I'm a
liberal I'm votin Hillary but here's the
chin there a lot of female economists
it's almost all female economists if
they came to you and said hey listen
here's the truth you'll be paid just as
much as a man if you do the same
schooling and do the same job wouldn't
you be thrilled
wouldn't you be relieved
instead they get mad why because it
removes an excuse from them IIIi think
that's pretty - let's get - uh well okay
let's look at black lives matter let's
look at right now you know racism versus
actual racism um look no further than we
talked about this Shaun King and Rachel
Dolezal both of them are not black but
they claim they're black and they they
did so to either get false scholarships
with shunkan with the Oprah deal grants
they reported false hate crimes Twitter
followers Twitter followers Rachel
Dolezal got a job at the n-double a-c-p
that which could they have some white
workers but clearly would have been more
likely to go to a black person they
thought all right I have a better chance
at getting a scholarship or a grant if I
claim some kind of victim status so what
do they have to do white people like
them they first have to convince black
people these are white people that they
are victims that they are being
marginalized that racism is more alive
than ever and then convince them that
they're black so it's it's a two-stage
trick there that they have to do and
they thought well I have a better chance
of getting these things done
scholarships grants and guess what they
were right their only problem was they
were discovered let's go - okay provide
LGBTQA AIP you know it used to be LGBTQ
I think at one point I might have been
LGB I don't even think they really cared
about the B it was just sort of assumed
that you were both LNG um it wasn't
enough so now they have to include
asexuals pansexuals transgenders right
this all they all have to be a vocal
members of the gestapo cult allies right
so why is there an incentive to do that
well yeah of course Hey look at the
entertainment industry we've talked
about this where they're vastly
over-represented but it's not enough to
just be gay or to be trans you use it to
sue a bakery out of business or a
pizzeria or bed-and-breakfast and make
millions or to sue an employer in HR you
can find countless suits made based on
discrimination against LGBTQ a AIP
and you can find suits now with
pansexuals with asexuals intersexual all
of these different subgroups that
they've created that guess what at the
end of that victim rainbow is always a
pot of gold it's always a lawsuit it's
always a scholarship it's always a grant
there are many instances in this book
there's really were
with young Americans where they can
choose okay let me work really hard be
the best in my class be the best in my
field learn the trade start a business
or simply claim that I'm a victim of
this underclass and there are very real
scenarios more common than than not I
would say where you are incentivized to
be a victim and that destroys the human
spirit keep that in mind
talk to you next week
[Music]
you